bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du Figaro on est heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle soirée
électorale vous avez raison d'être avec
nous parce que vous allez pouvoir
commenter réagir poser vos questions en
direct pour réagir bien sûr au résultat
qui vont vous être donnés dans un peu
moins d'une heure en direct ici sur le
site du Figaro voici déjà un premier
chiffre c'est une estimation qui nous
est donnée par l'Ifop ce sont les
chiffres de l'abstention
28% chiffre qu'on va commenter avec vous
vous allez réagir vous allez commenter
et on va les commenter également avec
nos invités en plateau avec Anne fielda
bonsoir grand reporter au Figaro
biographe d'Emmanuel Macron faut-il le
rappeler et on cherche et biographes à
ce titre et en charge et en charge des
portraits au Figaro troisième cahier
dernière page Guillaume roquette
directeur de la rédaction du Figaro
Magazine bonsoir Guillaume et Gael
Slimane président et fondateur
cofondateur de l'Institut odoxa
partenaire chaque semaine avec bac bonne
Consulting d'un sondage pour Le Figaro
avant de vous donner la parole avant de
vous donner la parole chers internaute
également je vous propose d'aller tout
de suite au deuxième étage du Figaro
plein cœur de la news room on va
retrouver Bruno Dre juste après le
générique
[Musique]
bonsoir Vincent et bonsoir à tous les
internautes je suis donc dans la
newsroom c'est à dire le cœur de la
rédaction du Figaro là où travaille tous
les journalistes qu'il soit rédacteur ou
à l'édition c'est-à-dire chargé de
relire corriger et mettre en ligne les
articles je vais vous présenter un petit
peu différents services qui sont à pied
d'oeuvre ce soir lors de cette soirée
électorale a commencé par le service
politique venait avec moi Maxime Laury
donc qui filme ces images j'ai
rendez-vous avec Jim jarazey qui est
rédacteur en chef adjoint du service
politique bonsoir Jim bons alors comment
vous êtes vous organisé pour ce soir et
l'organisation est sensiblement la même
qu'au premier tour de la présidentielle
on a eu 15 jours un peu pour réadapter
notre organisation donc à nouveau on
s'est réuni avec les différents services
du journal les secrétaires de rédaction
la rédaction web que vous avez derrière
vous la direction artistique pour
préparer la soirée être les plus
complets les plus réactifs possibles à
partir de la tombée des résultats donc à
20h à la fois sur le web et puis sur
l'organisation de nos différentes
éditions print il y a trois éditions
donc ce soir une qui va boucler à 21h la
seconde à 23 heures et une dernière
édition qui sera évidemment la plus
complète et qui sera la plus diffusée en
France qui boucle à 1h du matin donc on
aura là on aura vraiment eu le temps de
d'injecter toutes les informations au
niveau des journalistes comme au premier
tour on a des journalistes qui sont
mobilisés ici les journalistes du
service politique qui sont qui sont
présents à la rédaction on a aussi
évidemment des journalistes sur les
terrains dans les QG donc au Champs de
Mars pour suivre la soirée électorale
d'Emmanuel Macron et puis dans le 16e
arrondissement où se déroule la soirée
de Marine Le Pen donc voilà globalement
on n'a pas changé pas grand chose par
rapport au premier tour c'est juste
qu'on a un peu resserré les effectifs
sur forcément les deux candidats et puis
on va essayer de faire les choses les de
la façon encore une fois la plus
réactive et précise possible ce soir
est-ce que vous avez le même nombre de
pages à écrire demain dans le journal
alors on a un tout petit peu plus de
pages qu'au premier tour on a on aura 15
pages précisément demain dans le journal
que vous allez pouvoir retrouver dans
les kiosques une première double page où
on va vraiment faire l'analyse globale
des résultats les grandes leçons qu'on
va pouvoir tirer du scrutin à commencer
par l'abstention on le sait déjà qui
s'annonce très élevé et puis ensuite on
déclinera une double page pour chaque
candidat d'abord évidemment le gagnant
ou la gagnante et puis une seconde
double page pour l'autre candidat et
puis ensuite on aura une grande carte de
France des résultats par commune ce qui
est vraiment toujours très instructif
pour voir cette France coupée en deux on
s'attend déjà à pouvoir voir ça de façon
très visuelle et puis dans les dans les
pages qui suivent on va commencer à
s'intéresser à la suite des événements
puisque en fait l'actualité politique va
être encore très dense et prochains
jours avec d'abord la constitution du
gouvernement qui s'annonce évidemment
inédite et crucial quelle que soit le
cas de figure et puis surtout la
campagne est législatives qui en fait va
commencer dès ce soir des 20h il va y
avoir les premiers les premières
stratégies dans chaque partie les
alliances les rapprochements pour se
scrutin qui se déroulera donc le les 12
et 19 juin prochain donc pour nous on
est encore au milieu de la route ce soir
la séquence politique électorale est
loin d'être terminée merci Jim et
rendez-vous tout à l'heure à 23h30 sur
Figaro life pour découvrir en direct la
Une du Figaro de demain c'est Alexis
Brézet en personne qui viendra nous la
présenter en direct à vous Vincent
merci beaucoup brune merci j mais je
salue Albert equiem tango Claudius qui
nous Albert qui nous rejoignent ce soir
sur la homepage du Figaro et je vous
salue également tous ceux qui nous
rejoignaient sur notre page Youtube
parce que là vous êtes présent même
depuis le milieu de l'après-midi en tout
cas avant même l'ouverture de ce live on
va tout de suite aller sur le champ de
marche où se trouve Matisse fleuret
envoyé spécial lui et Figaro live au
quartier général ou en tous les cas là
où sont réunis les partisans d'Emmanuel
Macron on vient de vous voir Mathis
Mathis quel est l'ambiance
alors
voilà petit souci de son une fois qu'il
est réglé on retournera au Champ de Mars
retrouvé Matisse fleuret on va peut-être
en profiter pour aller dans le bois de
Boulogne au Paillon d'arménanonville ou
sont réunis les partisans de Marine Le
Pen mais Mathis fleuret a retrouvé le
son donc on l'écoute
oui tout à fait j'ai retrouvé le son
Vincent alors ici c'est plutôt agité
mais pas particulièrement par les
militants par les journalistes il y a
énormément de journalistes ici vous le
voyez ici et bien c'est la place pour à
la fois les militants et les
journalistes juste derrière et bien
derrière cette barrière il y a des
places assises pour les ministres les
proches les parlementaires qui viendront
assister au discours d'Emmanuel Macron
et encore derrière juste sur la Tour
Eiffel et bien vous voyez des images de
campagne diffusées par les équipes
d'Emmanuel Macron notamment la série le
candidat du président diffusé sur
Youtube on a notamment vu des images où
il appelle Gérard Majax juste après le
débat en tout cas ici et bien tout le
monde attend évidemment les résultats à
20h puis la prise de parole du président
de la République candidat
et on va maintenant alors comme chose
pour une chose dans le bois de Boulogne
au Pavillon d'Armenonville rejoindre
Daphné karavaca au QG de Marine Le Pen
Daphné quel est l'ambiance sur place
Marine Le Pen et semble-t-il arrivé
bonsoir Vincent alors on est arrivé il y
a une heure environ la sécurité a
vérifié l'intégralité des sacs des
journalistes on en compte d'ailleurs 500
ici au Pavillon d'Armenon pour quasiment
autant d'invités d'après Caroline
Parmentier l'attaché presse de Marine Le
Pen et pour l'instant pas d'horaire pour
une éventuelle prise de parole de la
candidate à l'issue du scrutin dans la
salle comme vous le voyez derrière moi
la priorité est donnée aux caméras et
pour l'instant il y a beaucoup plus de
journalistes que d'inviter et comparé à
la soirée du premier tour la tension
monte définitivement d'un cran
beaucoup justement suivent ça on
rappelle le premier chiffre il y a
beaucoup de questions que vous nous
posez en ce moment sur le chat du Figaro
pour l'instant le seul chiffre le
chiffre fiable dont on dispose ce sont
les estimations de l'abstention 28%
selon l'Ifop est-ce que Gaëlle ce sont
des estimations que vous avez en tous
les cas les mêmes dont vous disposez à
géodoxa oui on n'aura pas beaucoup de
surprises sur le niveau de la
participation et de l'abstention de
toute façon parce que la projection du
du vote et des informations de 17 heures
donne une photo assez fiable à un
pouillame près de ce qu'on retrouvera à
20h donc on va aussi aller entre 27,27,9
et 28 4-285 d'abstention donc l'inverse
pour la participation et c'est tout à
fait en ligne avec ce qu'on pouvait
anticiper dans les dans les sondages
qu'on avait réalisé avant le scrutin
c'est-à-dire une abstention finalement
assez comparable à celle du premier tour
avec un petit bonus si j'ose dire un
petit un petit peu comme on l'avait
observé en 2017 il y avait une un
accroissement de l'abstention pour pour
une part ce qu'on observe d'habitude
c'est que beaucoup d'électeurs qui ont
voté au premier tour refusent de le
faire au second et que c'est en partie
compensée par des abstentionnistes du
premier tour qui se décident à aller
voter au second tour est-ce que on sait
d'ailleurs si c'est ce qui se passe là
aujourd'hui c'est surtout pour le dur
c'est trop tôt pour le dire mais c'est
évidemment comme ça que ça se passe à
chaque fois ce qui va jouer il est trop
tôt pour faire des projections sur les
résultats il est hors de question d'en
parler mais ce qui va jouer c'est c'est
l'abstention différentielle est-ce que
l'un des candidats aura réussi à
mobiliser davantage son camp que l'autre
sachant qu'il y a deux enjeux un pour
Marine Le Pen qui est que son électorat
est structurellement poreux à
l'abstention le profil sociologique des
électeurs Le Pen ressemble beaucoup au
profit des abstentionnistes donc ça une
forte abstention ça pourrait être
handicap pour Marine Le Pen mais à
l'inverse Emmanuel Macron il a un petit
problème c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
d'électeurs qui nous disait dans les
enquêtes qu'il n'était pas qu'ils
allaient voter pour lui mais il n'en
étaient pas du tout sûr parce que
c'était un vote par défaut on pense
notamment à des électeurs mélenchonistes
donc ça crée un petit suspense est-ce
que ce gap d'abstention ce point
supplémentaire ou ces deux points
supplémentaires vont jouer en faveur de
l'un ou l'autre candidat il est trop tôt
pour le dire alors je tiens à répondre
également aux personnes avant de vous
donner la parole à et Guillaume qui nous
dit sur le chat que l'élection est déjà
faite que on a déjà des chiffres
effectivement il y a des chiffres qui
circulent mais pour l'instant ce ne sont
pas encore des chiffres fiables on
devrait nous en recevoir pour rien vous
cacher d'ici un quart d'heure 20 minutes
normalement et qui seront les premières
estimations fiables parce que on précise
peut-être Gaëlle les problèmes des
estimations fiables ce sont les sondages
ce sont les premiers dépouillement oui
c'est-à-dire que l'estimation ce que
vous voyez à 20h c'est très important de
le dire aux gens qui nous regardent et
qui nous écoutent ce que vous voyez à
20h c'est le fruit du dépouillement de
qui ne peuvent pas se soustraire à
l'interrogation et qui ne peuvent pas
mentir donc l'estimation c'est à 20h
effectivement
nous l'aurons un petit peu avant tout ce
qui circule dans la journée au mieux ce
sont de vrais sondages effectuer le jour
du vote mais qui souvent ne sont pas
plus précis que les sondages du vendredi
et au pire ce sont des intox donc chaque
institut de sondage s'est engagé auprès
de la commission des songettes d'âge
pour ne pas communiquer de chiffre de
sondage que nous réaliserions le jour du
vote il est très important que les
téléspectateurs les nos auditeurs ne
croient pas n'y croient pas alors on a
eu quelques surprises déjà d'ailleurs
selon des premières indications donc je
message à mon avis qui dit qu'elle
suspense s'est plié depuis le 10 avril
non c'est pas forcément plié ce soir
Anne peut-être un commentaire sur ce
chiffre de l'abstention puisque si il
s'avérait s'il se confirmait ce serait
le plus haut taux d'abstention de
l'histoire de la Cinquième République
depuis l'élection 1969 et 69 qui était
une élections assez particulière pas du
tout la même le même cas de figure
puisqu'à l'époque tout le monde avait
dit c'est l'élection c'est blanc bonnet
contre bonnet blanc
power Pompidou c'est le contexte n'avait
rien à voir c'est à dire qu'on trouvait
que c'était deux offres très très
semblables de gaullistes et deux offres
très semblables alors que là on a
vraiment deux offres très dissemblables
et
surtout la une offre politique avec ce
qu'on avait déjà dit après le premier
tour des parties traditionnels qui ont
disparu de la scène
de partie traditionnelles de droite et
de gauche qui qui ne sont pas au
deuxième tour ce qui est quand même ça
avait déjà été la dernière fois en 2017
mais François Fillon avec quand même
malgré les affaires malgré le contexte
défavorable avait eu un score au premier
tour de près de 20% et là on est passé à
moins de 5% donc voilà Guillaume c'est
un commentaire sur ce chiffre alors
évidemment ce taux d'abstention élevé
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
démocratie j'allais dire même si c'est
subjectif que quand même on sauve les
meubles entre guillemets parce que on
est quand même à nouveau dans un
scénario assez atypique avec d'un côté
un candidat président sortant qui
rassemble très largement mais qui a fait
disparaître les parties traditionnelles
Anne rappelait à l'instant le score
calamiteux des républicains en premier
tour celui des socialistes et si bas
qu'on a quasiment oublié moins de 2% et
donc on peut imaginer cet électorat
traditionnel
qui pourrait en quelque sorte être
découragé ou d'écouter de la vie
politique et puis il y a une autre
candidate Marine Le Pen qui est quand
même très clivant par son par son
positionnement et pourtant on va dire
que
alors certes c'est pas les trois quarts
des Français qui vont voter mais si on
se compare à d'autres grandes
démocraties comme les États-Unis par
exemple je trouve qu'on qu'on s'en sort
pas trop mal alors je vais vous donner
la parole Gaëlle des on vient de voir
des images des premiers dépouillement on
va retourner
au deuxième étage du Figaro parce que on
va avoir une batterie de chiffres ce
soir qui va être analysée pour décrypter
ces résultats alors au Figaro ils sont
recueillis par le service de la data et
c'est là donc on retrouve brune Audrey
oui je me trouve donc désormais au fil
data donc c'est le service qui collecte
la data la donnée en français et qui la
met en forme avant de la publier sur le
site je suis avec donc le rédacteur en
chef de ce service Stéphane solnier
bonsoir bonsoir Stéphane est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer en quoi votre
service est un rouage essentiel lors
d'une soirée électorale alors tout
simplement parce que nous sommes au
centre du dispositif en lien avec le
service politique nous c'est ici d'abord
qui arrive les estimations les chiffres
les résultats par la suite tout au long
de la nuit que nous allons collecter que
nous allons traiter analyser afin déjà
dans un premier lieu de pouvoir les
restituer sur le site du Figaro mais
aussi plus tard ou pendant la soirée à
travers des analyses notamment des
cartes des infographies qui vont
alimenter au fur et à mesure le site web
mais également le journal un peu plus
tard dans la soirée est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter un petit peu votre
équipe qui est juste derrière nous oui
alors c'est une équipe très hétéroclite
elle est composée de 8 personnes vous
vous allez retrouver à la fois des Data
journalistes qui sont donc en charge de
collecter l'information pour la traiter
l'analyser et la restituer vous allez
avoir un développeur qui va faire le
lien technique entre le ministère de
l'Intérieur et le site internet vous
allez avoir des infographes qui vont
reproduire les cartes et les
infographies afin de les rendre
disponibles sur le journal papier qui
sera disponible demain pour nos abonnés
est-ce qu'il y a des pièges ou des
difficultés dans lesquelles il faut pas
tomber ce soir alors non je parlerai pas
de piège je dirais plus simplement qu'il
y a en fait surtout un gros travail qui
a été fait en amont pour éviter
justement ces pièges et faire en sorte
que cette soirée se passe vraiment de la
meilleure façon en revanche nous avons
mis sur le site du Figaro un dispositif
inédit de mise à disposition des
résultats en temps réel et à la fois un
décompte qui va avoir lieu maintenant
dans quelques minutes et qui nous
donnera qui d'Emmanuel Macron ou de
Marine Le Pen sera notre nouveau ou
notre nouvelle chef de l'État et j'ai
pour ma part l'immense privilège d'avoir
appuyé sur le bouton à 20h pour voir le
révéler sur le site internet merci
Stéphane donc rendez-vous à 20h sur Le
Figaro.fr pour découvrir cette
infographie du fil data animé à vos
Vincent voilà et on aura exactement même
raison même motif ce sera pareil sur
figarolive merci à Stéphane Saunier et
sur la base d'ailleurs des résultats qui
sont recueillis par le service dirigé
par Stéphane Saunier vous pourrez savoir
quel est le résultat dans les lieux qui
vous sont chers dans les lieux qui vous
intéressent également et ce sera un live
qui sera animé à partir de 21h50 par
Thibault Gauthier et Alban Barthélemy
vous leur demandez le lieu qui vous
intéresse il le cherche il vous donne le
résultat on va aller tout de suite sur
le Champ de Mars retrouver Matisse
fleuret pour avoir un peu des éléments
d'ambiance comment est-ce que ça
continue d'affluer dans le dans le
centre de Paris et comment s'organise la
soirée et quand est attendu le président
candidat
oui Vincent alors
Vincent pour l'instant les militants
commencent à arriver ça commence à
bouger par rapport à tout à l'heure où
c'était plutôt calme j'ai pu parler
quand même à quelques militants alors
ils sont tous confiants et tous sont
venus pour la même chose pour vivre pour
vivre ce moment tout simplement
on vous redonne la parole on va aller
dans le dans le 16e arrondissement
retrouver Daphné karavaca pareil pour
savoir comment
évolue l'ambiance et est-ce qu'il y a un
petit peu plus de militants en tout cas
plus de militants que de journalistes
puisque c'était pas le cas tout à
l'heure
on avance
alors pour l'heure ce qu'on sait mais ça
reste à confirmer à ce stade c'est qu'en
cas de victoire Marine Le Pen a dit à
plusieurs reprises qu'elle souhaitaient
faire une grande déambulation dans Paris
depuis l'année tropole royale de la
basilique Saint-Denis en passant par les
Invalides pour terminer ensuite au pied
de la statue du général de Charles de
Gaulle sur les Champs-Élysées on a
également pu entendre qu'il y aurait
plusieurs car venant de provinces pour
suivre Marine Le Pen sur son trajet ses
informations ne sont malheureusement pas
confirmés par les équipes de la
candidate qui ne nous les ont pas donné
puisque on nous a simplement dit qu'ici
aucune déambulations n'était prévue pour
le moment on reviendra bien évidemment
vers vous dès qu'on en saura plus vous
nous donnerez tout de suite des éléments
d'ambiance j'en reviens peut-être vous
le disiez tout à l'heure sur sur
l'abstention et puis après on reviendra
justement sur la campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron alors il y a un élément en rebond
à ce que disait Guillaume qui est tout à
fait exact nous on se plaint parce qu'on
est quand même en France on est quand
même bien lotis par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres pays aux États-Unis qui a un
système qui peut qui peut nous
ressembler où on a un électeur sur deux
en gros sur qui va s'abstenir il y a
quand même un paramètre qu'il faudra
regarder de près ce soir et qu'on ne
peut pas connaître pour le moment il y a
l'abstention d'une part et il y a le
vote blanc est nul d'autres parts or on
a atteint un record de vente blanc et
nul en 2017 et dans les sondages que
nous avons réalisé avant l'élection on
anticipe des niveaux alors c'est très
fragile mais on verra si ça se confirme
autour de 13%. si 11% en 2017 exactement
j'étais 11% 11 11 et demi si on est à 13
ou à 14 que vous ajoutez à cela 28%
d'abstention ça veut dire qu'on aurait
plus de 4 électeurs sur 10 qui
n'auraient pas voté et vous avez des
tableaux intéressants qu'on peut trouver
online où vous verrez ce que chaque
président élu depuis 1965 avec comme
base de soutien au second tour en
intégrant le vote blanc est nul et
l'abstention et on se rend compte que
jamais aucun président à part Chirac en
2002 n'a bénéficié du soutien de plus de
50% des français quand on tenait compte
de l'abstention et du vote blanc est nul
mais qu'en général on tournait entre 40
et 45%. chaque président élu peut
compter sur 40 à 45%. il est probable
que cette fois on en sera très loin pour
Emmanuel Macron compte tenu de cette
part d'abstention et Macron ou pour
Marine Le Pen voilà
quel que soit le vainqueur ce soir
peut-être on va essayer de voir si
Mathis fleuret on a on a récupéré le son
avec Mathis fleuret et justement voir
quel est quel est l'ambiance et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que Mathis nous
disait à l'instant que en tous les cas
les militants qui arrivent eux sont
assez sûr Mathis fleuret
quel est précisément le si vous nous
entendez quel est le programme pour le
président candidat ce soir
alors il ne nous entendent pour
l'instant il n'est pas là on lui
demandera le dit qu'il sera de retour
un mot peut-être sur le la campagne
d'entre deux tours de d'Emmanuel Macron
Anne qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé et en
particulier qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé
pendant le débat face à Marine Le Pen
deux choses pendant la campagne qui m'a
frappé c'est ça
extrême plasticité que m'avait dit
byrout qui avait dit ça à propos de
Chirac il est il est plastique et là
j'ai trouvé que Emmanuel Macron aussi
avait fait preuve d'une extrême
plasticité
qu'il n'a dont il n'a pas fait preuve en
revanche lors du débat face à Marine Le
Pen où là
[Musique]
c'est presque à se demander si c'était
une stratégie c'est-à-dire que il a
tellement eu dans la dans la pose il a
tellement endossé presque avec une
espèce de plaisir de morgue cette
fameuse arrogance qu'on lui reprochait
ce mépris qu'on lui reprochait c'est
presque à se demander si c'était pas une
stratégie pour remettre ça son
adversaire dans la posture que dans
laquelle elle était
cinq ans auparavant donc ça j'avais été
très frappé par ça parce que alors que
tout le monde tout le monde l'avait mis
en garde et qu'il le sait que c'est très
bien contre cette excès ce travers il
l'a fait de façon
ostensible et excessive
à l'inverse on parle cette internaute
nous parle au sujet de Marine Le Pen
nous dit je pense que beaucoup
d'électeurs qui comptaient voter Le Pen
ont été refroidi par son dernier débat
est-ce que c'est votre avis Guillaume ah
moi j'ai toujours pas compris si c'était
passé effectivement comment est-ce que
Marine Le Pen a renoncé à tous ce
qu'elle avait comme argument contre
Emmanuel Macron pour essayer de de le le
mettre en difficulté
elle a eu une demi phrase sur l'affaire
mckinzee qui certes n'avait rien de de
choquant en matière de l'égalité pour
les pratiques de recours à ces grands
cabinets de conseils internationaux mais
qui politiquement avait un sens elle est
parvenue sur ce président qui avait très
envie d'emmerder les antivacs et qui
apparaissaient là comme manifestant
l'arrogance dont Anne parler à l'instant
même sur le cœur de son offre politique
c'est-à-dire l'immigration et le et
l'islamisme elle était
extraordinairement en retrait comme si
elle avait avant tout pour objectif de
ce des diaboliser j'aime pas ce terme
parce qu'il est un peu ridicule je sais
pas où est le diable dans la vie
politique peut-être pas toujours là où
on croit mais en tout cas
une un besoin d'être légitime de se
faire accepter et par rapport à un
électorat qui lui est profondément
protestataire qui est en colère contre
le système j'imagine qu'effectivement ça
a dû les déconcerter on verra ce soir si
ça s'est traduit dans les urnes
exactement on va le voir il y a trois
scénarios pour
Emmanuel Macron Gaëlle
première premier scénario
la victoire la victoire on dit à plus de
55% deuxième scénario la victoire a
moins de 55 à 55% ou à moins de 55%. et
troisième scénario la défaite est-ce que
vous pouvez nous commenter quels sont
les enjeux derrière ces trois scénarios
oui alors on dit la victoire a plus de
55 % on va dire une victoire qui se
rapprocherait des 60
serait une victoire
correcte
honorable solide pour lui je rappelle
quand même que c'est un match retour au
match aller les deux adversaires c'était
séparés sur un score de 66% en faveur
d'Emmanuel Macron donc faire 60 59 c'est
déjà être 6-7 points en dessous mais
pour quelqu'un qui a un bilan qui a un
Kenya derrière lui bah ça se
comprendrait très bien et donc ça c'est
le premier scénario qui a un scénario
réalisé un score autour des 60% un peu
en dessous on a un président qui serait
nettement conforté
du Lot ce que j'indiquais tout à l'heure
sur la part de votre blanc et nul et
d'abstance sioniste parce que prenons le
scénario médian actuellement dans les
sondages pré-électoraux parle pas du
jour du vote on était autour en moyenne
entre 53,57 donc autour des 55 % et bien
avec 55 % et 40 % de Français inscrits
sur liste qui ne vont pas voter soit
parce qu'ils s'abstiennent soit parce
qu'ils choisissent pas en faisant un
vote blanc une île ça fait 33% de
soutien c'est-à-dire que même avec 55%
des voix ou 56% des voix ça
représenterait 33% de Français qui l'ont
choisi comme président au second tour
donc le scénario médian est déjà un peu
fragile et alors si on était sur un
scénario en deçà de
55%, 53 54 c'est pas une défaite mais ça
rendrait très compliqué probablement la
possibilité d'agir et de gouverner en
menant une politique pour laquelle enfin
sur laquelle il était assez clair et des
réformes qui sont des réformes qui
nécessiteront pour passer un minimum
d'assentiment en général et donc ça
génère de la fragilité surtout que notre
système est ainsi fait qu'en général il
y a confirmation législative et donc on
pourrait se retrouver dans des
situations invraisemblables ou un
président soutenu par un tiers des
Français comme j'expliquais tout à
l'heure se retrouverait en situation
d'avoir une majorité très large et de
pouvoir faire techniquement ce qu'il
veut on va regarder également les
scénarios pour Marine Le Pen mais
d'abord on va retrouver brune d'Audrey
qui se retrouve qui se trouve toujours
dans la newsroom du Figaro avant de nous
rejoindre ici en plateau avec Frédéric
Picard le rédacteur en chef de la page
d'accueil du Figaro celle où vous voyez
quand vous êtes sur le site du Figaro et
bien précisément en direct de la
rédaction pour vous présenter les
coulisses et les visages de ceux qui
bâtissent chaque jour Le Figaro et je
vous présente donc Frédéric Picardo
alors Frédéric Picard est rédacteur en
chef au Figaro en charge notamment de la
tranche du soir et c'est lui qui est aux
manettes de ce second tour Frédéric
comment vous êtes organisé ce soir bien
on est bien organisé je rigole parce que
j'ai deux trois collègues qui faisaient
des blagues à l'instant donc je pense à
on est bien organisé des des
collaborateurs qui sont évidemment dans
les QG pour ne remonter le maximum
d'informations et nous faire revivre ça
évidemment aussi un live qui va
fonctionner qui fonctionne depuis ce
matin qui marche très très bien et que
vous pouvez suivre évidemment
et puis voilà quoi donc la vidéo bien
sûr avec vous avec Vincent sur votre
plateau avec plein d'invités et vous
quel est votre rôle en particulier en
tant que rédacteur en chef disons
essayer d'être coordinateur de tout cela
que ça fonctionne avec la data donc vous
parliez tout à l'heure avec avec
Stéphane le site le print que tout ça
soit le plus coordonné possible pour que
ça aille le mieux possible et qu'on
donne un maximum d'informations d'un
minimum de temps juste vous étiez déjà
là le 10 avril dernier pour le premier
tour est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui
a évolué par rapport au premier tour ce
soir non évolué non disons que on a
l'habitude de ces grands événements que
ce soit celui-ci ou d'autres événements
un peu moins un peu moins drôle on a on
a l'habitude donc on prend des qui sont
extrêmement rompus à cet exercice qui
sont extrêmement assez calmes de façon à
ce qu'on puisse transmettre toujours une
information qui est toujours vérifiée
même si le temps qui est un parti pour
la donnée le plus court possible jusqu'à
quelle heure on aura de l'information
sur le Figaro.fr les dernières les
derniers chiffres actualisés par exemple
les chiffres actualisés tout au long de
la soirée cette nuit évidemment nous
transmettons le manche si l'on peut dire
ainsi à notre à notre équipe qui se
trouve à de l'autre côté de des
États-Unis en Californie qui va suivre
et demain matin dès 5 heures c'est
l'équipe de la matinale de Marion Joseph
qui reprend les choses pour suivre et
pour développer tout ça toute au long de
la journée merci Frédéric on vous laisse
travailler et quant à moi je vais
prendre l'ascenseur et je vous rejoins
dans le studio Haussmann à tout de suite
Vincent roux merci beaucoup on va
rejoindre également Timothée d'Hélène
normalement qui devrait être avec nous
d'une minute à l'autre il sera sur la
moto qui suivra l'équipe du ou pas
vainqueur de la soirée je voudrais faire
un point également sur les puisqu'on
parlait des scénarios pareil trois
scénarios pour Marine Le Pen Gaëlle
scénario 1 une défaite à moins de 40 à
moins de 45 %, une défaite à 45 ou plus
et troisième scénario une victoire alors
le scénario de la victoire on
s'appesantit pas dessus ce serait la
divine surprise pour pour Marine Le Pen
et elle mettrait d'accord tous ceux qui
l'avaient critiqué notamment Éric
Zemmour en essayant qu'une chance de
l'emporter le scénario d'une défaite pas
trop large une défaite à moins de 55%
c'est un scénario très intéressant pour
elle je pense pour l'avenir parce que
c'est finalement un score normal de
candidats normales de second tour qui
affronte un adversaire un score
gauche-droite un royal Sarkozy du
Mitterrand Chirac et donc perdre sur
même symbolique
ce serait déjà pas mal pour elle en
revanche si elle perd sur un score
au-delà de 55 et qui se rapproche des 60
même si ce serait toujours il y a à peu
près aucun doute qu'elle fera mieux
qu'il y a 5 ans même si ce serait
toujours une dizaine de points ou 8
points de plus que la dernière fois
ce serait insuffisant et ça prêterait le
flanc ça réactiverait toutes les
critiques encore une fois notamment de
ceux qui sont les tenants d'une union
des droites et de la ligne Zemmour
Marion maréchal qui dirait et ce serait
assez crédible elle ne peut pas gagner
ça ne sert à rien elle pourrait se
représenter dix fois il n'y arrivera pas
et donc il faut procéder autrement donc
il y a un vrai enjeu je pense
politiquement pour elle et pour la ligne
stratégique du RN à tendre vers une
défaite s'il devait y avoir une défaite
à moins de 55%. il y a quand même
peut-être
des surprises que ce soit on peut pas
encore en dire mais en tous les cas des
scores étonnants qui qui nous
parviennent
vous avez regardé également la campagne
de Marine Le Pen et vous avez l'habitude
de ses campagnes qu'est-ce qu'elle vous
a inspiré en tous les cas cette campagne
sa campagne d'entre deux tours
a été
on pensait qu'elle changerait de
registre ce qu'elle n'a pas fait si ce
n'est après le débat on a l'impression
qu'elle a refait le match comme on dit
qu'elle a répondu ce qu'elle aurait dû
dire à Emmanuel Macron lors du débat en
lui disant que en la méprisant il
méprisait les Français etc c'est réparti
on a l'impression qu'elle lui sont venus
une fois le débat terminé quoi donc ce
qui était un peu un peu dommage enfin
pour elle donc
voilà sinon après elle a fait une
campagne traditionnelle elle a fait du
terrain mais elle a elle a pas été elle
a pas été très offensive alors justement
on va retourner au quartier général de
Marine Le Pen pavillon d'arménanville
dans le bois de Boulogne où on retrouve
Daphné Caravaca qui se trouve avec des
militants
normalement on va pouvoir enlever alors
nous essayons dans le Nord alors vous
êtes dans quel état d'esprit ce soir on
est confiant on est à quelques minutes
du résultat il y a quelques estimations
qui viennent de tomber on verra on sait
pas il reste encore 30 minutes mais on
est confiant parce que jusqu'à la
dernière seconde jusqu'à la dernière
seconde de cette campagne on a vu une
ferveur sur le terrain qu'on n'avait
jamais vu une attente et une envie de
changement donc voilà jusque à la
dernière seconde on y croit du coup et
en fonction des résultats qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire ce soir
si Marine Le Pen était lui bien sûr
c'est les législatives pour construire
une majorité présidentielle autour de
Marine Le Pen si des fêtes il y a ce
sont aussi les législatives mais dans
une autre perspective c'est-à-dire avoir
un maximum d'élus pour surtout
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas la
majoritaire absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale pour ralentir son calendrier
législatif qu'il a annoncé lors de ce
second tour notamment la réforme des
retraites à 65 ans pour tous ça sera ça
l'enjeu très bien voilà ce qu'on pouvait
dire pour le moment ici au QG de Marine
Le Pen à quelques minutes des résultats
du second tour
on y croit encore dans l'entourage de
Marine Le Pen on devrait savoir
maintenant si cette espérance est fondée
ou pas dans moins d'une demi-heure on va
retrouver avant d'avoir le regard
justement sur cette campagne de Marine
Le Pen de Guillaume roquette on va
retrouver Timothée d'Hélène qui se
trouve devant le Figaro prêt à
enfourcher la moto pour suivre l'équipe
de la personne qui va gagner
tout à fait Vincent voilà pour l'instant
je suis devant les locaux du Figaro dans
le 9e arrondissement de Paris 14
boulevard Haussmann plus précisément et
dès l'annonce des résultats et bien nous
ferons en sorte de ne rien rater de ne
rater aucune seconde de cette soirée
électorale et donc je partirai sur la
moto en direction et bien de l'Elysée
dans le cas d'une victoire d'Emmanuel
Macron en direction du pavillon
d'hermenonville dans le bois de Boulogne
dans le cadre d'une victoire de Marine
Le Pen et donc ensemble pardon nous
pourrons vivre et bien les premiers
instants suite à ce résultat donc les
premiers instants d'Emmanuel Macron
réélu ou bien de Marine Le Pen élu
présidente dans le cas d'une victoire
d'Emmanuel Macron nous partirons du 8e
arrondissement l'Élysée 55 boulevard
Saint-Honoré et nous partirons en
direction du Champ de Mars dans le 7e
arrondissement pour et bien ce cortège
présidentiel un cortège qui sera
évidemment très fourni des dizaines et
des dizaines de journalistes de
confrères qui seront également sur leur
moto dans ce dans ce cortège donc dans
le cas d'une victoire de Marine Le Pen
et bien suite à son discours qu'elle
prononcera dans son QG de campagne au
Pavillon d'arménonville je le disais
dans le 16e arrondissement de Paris
ensuite et bien selon nos informations
elles effectuera une déambulation dans
les rues de Paris dans des lieux
hautement symboliques nous dit-elle une
déambulance une déambulation qui
pourrait l'amener du côté des Invalides
du côté également de la statue du
général de Gaulle sur les Champs-Élysées
ce sont donc des instants que nous
pourrons vivre ensemble sur la moto du
Figaro pour cette soirée donc je vous
ferai vivre tous ces instants nous
essaierons de nous approcher au plus
près évidemment de la voiture soit
d'Emmanuel Macron soit de Marine Le Pen
ce sera aux alentours alors pour ce qui
est d'Emmanuel Macron on nous dit qu'il
devrait dans le cas d'une victoire
quitter l'Élysée aux alentours de 21h15
21h30 pour se rendre au Champ de Mars
pour Marine Le Pen on ne sait pas encore
tout à fait dans tous les cas dès 20h
dès les résultats je partirai sur la
moto donc pour rejoindre Emmanuel Macron
ou Marine Le Pen et ensuite vous faire
vivre ses premiers instants de président
ou de présidente élu et ou réélu on va
voir ça justement dans une vingtaine de
minutes Guillaume un commentaire
justement d'abord sur la campagne de
l'entre-deux-tours de Marine Le Pen on a
compris que vous aviez été étonné pour
ne pas dire stupéfait par sa prestation
lors du lors du débat c'est le cas
également sur le reste de sa campagne
c'est 15 derniers jours non parce que là
pour le coup sur sa campagne elle est
restée dans la stratégie qui avait été
gagnante au premier tour contraire
exemmour en particulier consistant à se
focaliser sur les enjeux de pouvoir
d'achat
en partant du principe que tout le reste
de son programme c'est-à-dire le tout ce
qui relève de l'identité de
l'immigration de de l'islamisme que tout
cela est déjà considéré comme acquis par
ces électeurs
peut-être que du coup en ce en étant
plus institutionnel dans son dans son
approche elle a
déconcerté est-ce que ça a démotivé on
ne sait pas on le verra à 20h une partie
de de ces électeurs
en apparaissant comme en quelque sorte
entrer dans le dans le dans le système
mais en même temps elle s'est dit que
c'était la seule façon de convaincre une
majorité d'arrêter de faire de faire
peur
on rappelle qu'en 2017 Emmanuel Macron
avait eu le double de voix de Marine Le
Pen 10 millions pour Marine Le Pen 20
millions pour Emmanuel Macron donc on va
voir ce que ça donne mais en présentant
la situation comme cela on voit à quel
point l'équation et complexe d'une
marine Le Pen qui doit à la fois être
suffisamment le reflet de ses colères
françaises pour pour exister mais tout
en étant entre guillemets crédible comme
une présidente comme une chef de l'État
et c'est très difficile d'avoir les les
deux les deux en même temps un point sur
les popularités respectives des deux
candidats ce qui est troublant c'est
qu'elles sont assez comparables on a
avec le Figaro on a réalisé un salon de
sondages de bilan de postes de du débat
Emmanuel Macron avait un ascendant sur
Marine Le Pen aux yeux des Français
alors je précise c'est pas un sondage
auprès de téléspectateurs captif qui
sont restés jusqu'au bout c'est un
sondage auprès de l'ensemble des
Français alors ceux qui n'ont eu aucun
écho sur ce débat nous ont pas répondu
mais sinon les autres nous ont répondu
et on se rendait compte que l'avantage
de Macron n'était pas énorme rien à voir
avec le débat il y a 5 ans quand on en
avait fait le post-est où il avait
recueilli trois fois plus de personnes
ayant trouvé convaincant que Marine Le
Pen là on était sur un étiage comparable
autour 55 45 entre les deux au global et
puis sur mesure par mesure et bien
finalement il y avait match entre les
deux on a testé les 12 outils 13 grands
domaines qu'ils ont abordés et on était
en gros à 48 47 sachant que je rejoins
ce que vous avez dit à ne Guillaume ce
qui est troublant c'est qu'elle
disposait d'atouts dans sa manche Marine
Le Pen sur des sujets majeurs pour les
gens notamment sur le pouvoir d'achat et
sur les retraites et lors du débat elle
elle les a très peu utilisés elle les a
un petit peu elle les a un petit peu
gâchées mais pour en revenir à votre
question Vincent en termes de
performance sur le débat et en termes de
popularité au code d'adhésion le niveau
de rejet d'un Emmanuel Macron chez une
partie des Français ne nous trompons pas
est assez comparable aujourd'hui au
niveau de rejet dans l'opinion des de
que dont patient Marine Le Pen il y a
une différence et c'est peut-être ce qui
sera décisif ce soir on verra c'est
qu'il est jugé plus crédible et plus
solide et partant de tempête par
longtemps ça peut être un atout
important pour pour l'opinion on le
saura dans un quart d'heure
juste pour revenir sur sur ce débat
parce dont on vient de revoir les images
Anne
est-ce que vous avez été il y a eu pas
mal de polémiques autour de la posture
d'Emmanuel Macron que nous ont révélés
les plans de coupe ou en tout cas les
contre-champs est-ce que ça ça vous a
étonné
dans un premier temps oui parce que ce
que pour ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que on avait tellement mis
en garde contre contre ce travers que
que c'était étonnant c'était tellement
outré on avait l'impression qu'il qu'il
voulait qu'il voulait enfin il est connu
pour ses dons d'acteurs à ce moment-là
il a un peu surjoué ce mépris ce côté du
professeur excédé par la médiocrité de
son élève un petit peu on a marqué par
son personnage et ce qui était amusant
c'est que pendant le débat on avait
l'impression qu'ils étaient un peu
affront renversé c'est-à-dire que celle
qui voulait faire présidentielle c'était
Marine Le Pen et celui qui était à
l'attaque en l'attaquant sur par exemple
sur sur l'Ukraine notamment sur les
attaques ont été sur les liens avec la
Russie en tout cas sur le c'était plus
Emmanuel Macron qui était offensif que
que Marine Le Pen donc c'était assez
surprenant lorsque lorsqu'on se
retrouvait avec un président sortant et
une challenger est-ce que ces
prestations il faut s'attendre à ce que
ce débat est un poids dans le résultat
ce soir or probablement marginalement
sans doute pas sans doute pas de façon
importante c'est très rare qu'un débat
est un grand poids moi je souscris tout
à fait à ce que vous avez dit sur sur ce
débat c'était affront renversé c'était
très étonnant Marine Le Pen n'a pas
réussi à
le pousser dans cette tranchement alors
quelle est elle était la Challenger
c'est celle qui devait rattraper un
retard au premier tour et Emmanuel
Macron a été étonnant aussi à vouloir
cultiver les les reproches qui lui sont
faits dans l'opinion en termes
d'arrogance donc j'ai le sentiment qui a
pas eu de grand match on avait des
sondages avant les avant le débat qui
aussi les entre 53 55% 56% l'oscillation
dépasse un petit peu sur la fin de la
campagne c'est ce corps là je suis pas
certain que c'est ce qui expliquera
cette le score que nous verrons ce soir
dans un instant en revanche
c'est vrai qu'elle aurait dû marquer des
points sur ce débat il n'y ait pas
parvenu on va retourner sur le Champ de
Mars retrouver Matisse fleuret à un
quart d'heure de
l'issue de cette campagne électorale à
un quart d'heure des résultats Quel est
l'ambiance sur place
vous voyez sur les images de Renan les
Blaise ça se remplit vous voyez le
contraste avec tout à l'heure comme vous
m'avez eu et les gens se disent
clairement confiance pour tout à l'heure
je vous dis que je vous ai dit que ça se
remplit et ça s'anime aussi tout à
l'heure il y a eu un chauffeur de salle
qui est passé avec un mégaphone et les
équipes du candidat m'ont confié qu'il y
aurait quelque chose après sont restés
très mystérieux sur la suite du
programme mais elles montrent qu'il
devrait se passer à un événement un
invité alors sur le ton de la blague on
m'a confié que ce ne serait pas Magic
System comme il y a 5 ans au Louvre
l'imagix system ni Gérard Majax en tous
les cas si vous avez des infos comme ça
vous nous les donner Mathis merci merci
beaucoup pour ces précisions et on
accueille le retour de brune de doré sur
splato bonsoir Vincent bonsoir à tous il
est bientôt 20h donc 19h46 très
exactement vous avez vous nous suivez
vous êtes très nombreux à commenter et à
réagir déjà aux premières informations
qui circulent on commence à avoir des
premières tendances on pourra vous
annoncer donc à 20h qui ira à l'Elysée
les cinq prochaines années Guillaume je
me retourne vers vous et vers l'édito
que vous avez écrit pour Le Figaro
Magazine ce week-end vous dites quel que
soit l'élu le monde ne s'arrête pas
vraiment
non alors pour être tout à fait honnête
je me souviens plus pourquoi j'ai écrit
ça mais d'abord je prenais pas beaucoup
de risques parce qu'a priori le soleil
se lèvera demain matin quel que soit le
pour ce soir le candidat élu mais
effectivement
ce qui est vrai c'est que les les quel
que soit le résultat de ce soir la
situation du pays
restera la même avec deux francs ou
peut-être trois francs si on reprend en
compte le score de Jean-Luc Mélenchon au
premier tour trois France qui ont de
moins en moins de choses en commun et
c'est très spectaculaire il y avait un
article passionnant
de Jérôme Fourquet cette semaine dans le
Figaro qui montrait le profil des
électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron et de Marine
Le Pen et vous avez deux France vous
avez la France qui va plutôt bien et la
France qui souffre vous avez aussi une
lutte des classes presque plus répartite
avec d'un côté les classes populaires de
gens qui ont un faible niveau à la fois
de revenus et d'études dans les
candidats de chez les électeurs de
Marine Le Pen et donc effectivement
cette cette situation là elle restera
demain et ce sera compliqué pour le pour
le président élu de de diriger le pays
avec une situation comme celle-ci
Anne j'ai
une qui était déjà là en 2017 avait été
rejeté par la majorité des Français
notamment en 2019 pour quoi on se
retrouve encore avec cette même affiche
aujourd'hui
il y a probablement un problème d'offre
concurrentes parce que effectivement
aucun autre concurrent on a vu qu'on
était pas que Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'était
pas loin d'arriver au deuxième tour mais
là aussi c'était la preuve d'un
bouleversement de du paysage politique
en fait on a l'impression que depuis
2017 la décomposition continue mais qui
a pas eu encore la recomposition elle
est en train de se faire mais elle n'est
pas encore faite donc du coup on se
retrouve avec les mêmes protagonistes
que 5 ans avant est-ce que oui je
voulais faire rebondir Gaël Slimane pour
savoir est-ce que c'est c'est le fait
d'avoir cette affiche qui est un peu
décevante qui explique un petit peu ce
taux d'abstention clairement on a on a
des Français qui à longueur d'enquête
nous disaient nous ne voulons pas de ce
match retour nous n'en voulons pas mais
comme la Diane l'offre peut aucune offre
politique n'arrive si à s'imposer alors
Emmanuel Macron a fait ce qu'il fallait
aussi pour faire exploser la gauche du
gouvernement et la droite du
gouvernement
et les mettre dans un état critique mais
forcément quand vous avez une offre
politique qui ne satisfait pas les
électeurs ils font deux choses ils
s'abstiennent dans des proportions très
importantes ça a été le cas au premier
tour et c'est ce sera encore le cas
aujourd'hui au second tour et en plus il
vote blanc ou nul ce qui est quand même
intéressant à prendre en compte je le
disais avant que vous n'arriviez sur
votre plateau on a on aura quel que soit
le résultat du vainqueur probablement le
niveau de soutien le plus faible pour un
président de la République ou une
présidente République si on tient compte
de l'abstention et du vote blanc nul on
aura probablement un tiers un peu plus
35% des électeurs qui auront choisi l'un
ou l'autre quels qu'ils soient c'est
trop faible mais c'est trop faible
d'accord mais ça pour autant ça n'enlève
pas la légitimité à l'élu ou réélu alors
la légitimité démocratique non parce que
la règle du jeu démocratique elle est
connue tous si vous n'êtes pas content
vous n'aviez qu'à aller voter ou à ne
pas voter blanc ou nul donc ça ça ne
l'enlève pas en revanche ça signifie
quelque chose sur le fait que les
Français ne souhaitent pas de ce choix
là le principe quand même de la du vote
et de la démocratie c'est que la
personne qui sera qui au manette soit
quelqu'un qui a été choisi normalement
par une majorité alors c'est jamais plus
de 51 % à cause de la part de votre
blanc annulé et d'abstention mais au
moins par 40 à 45% des Français si on
est sur un tiers ça devient très léger
et en plus Guillaume a raison quand on
regarde le détail dans dans les sondages
qu'on a pu réaliser des profils des
électorats effectivement il y a
plusieurs France mais on va parler des
deux France celle qui vote Le Pen et
celle qui vote Macron puisque ce soir
c'est la fiche du second tour elles
n'ont rien à voir vous avez des pas
entiers de la société qui ne voulaient
pas d'Emmanuel Macron et qui ont
probablement voté Marine Le Pen ce soir
et inversement on va y revenir justement
sur ce point là parce que là aussi on a
on a sans doute des spécificités dans
cette campagne Guillaume vous lirez
tellement de nuance par rapport à ce que
vient de dire Gaëlle c'est que c'est
difficile quand même de mettre les
abstentions au même niveau que les votes
blancs et nuls les votes blancs est nuls
je vais dans le bureau de vote et je dis
je refuse de choisir entre les deux
aucun des deux
façons
illégale parce que on n'a pas le droit
de révéler son vote et en fait en
refusant de voter ben il disait ce qu'il
faisait quand vous votez blanc il y a
rien dans l'enveloppe mais ça personne
exactement donc mais les
abstentionnistes par exemple moi je
connais les abstentionnistes qui disent
de toute façon moi j'aurais voté Macron
mais comme c'est gagné c'est pas la
peine d'y aller ou des électeurs de Le
Pen qui disent oh bah de toute façon les
sondages disaient qu'elle allait perdre
donc j'y suis pas allé donc est-ce que
le rejet elle-même en tout cas il est
plus clair et là il est chimiquement pur
avec les votes blancs ce qui d'ailleurs
pose une fois de plus le problème de
cette anomalie démocratique qui est la
confusion entre les votes c'est à dire
les gens qui choisissent de ne pas
choisir tout en faisant leurs devoirs
électoral et les gens qui embrassent le
le papier de leur candidat et ils
laissent du rouge à lèvres et donc le
truc est nul parce que on a pas le droit
ou qui mettent un petit message sur le
sur le bulletin et c'est interdit le
vote est nul automatiquement alors que
le sens a priori n'est pas le même alors
vous voyez peut-être à l'image en direct
il y a un petit décompte on est bientôt
à 7 minutes de la révélation des
premières estimations des résultats de
ce second tour moi j'ai ouvert mon
ordinateur et je vous lis je lis tous
vos commentaires vous êtes nombreux sur
les chats du figaro.fr et sur le chat
YouTube Figaro live chardon bleu sur le
Figaro.fr nous dit il a mis le chaos
donc il parle de Emmanuel Macron du
président le président mais le chaos
dans ce pays il a monté les gens les uns
contre les autres en disant tout et son
contraire avec la même aisance c'est
vrai que c'est un peu un paradoxe Anne
c'est à dire que Emmanuel Macron c'est
la première fois qu'il existe un front
anti Macron assumer on va dire
revendiquer
par notamment le camp Le Pen et pourtant
c'est un président qui jouit d'une
popularité assez grande il a fait un
très bon score quand même au premier
tour pour un président sortant en tout
cas supplémentaire à ce que on a vu chez
certains présidents
jusqu'au fondant pas popularité et score
qu'on fait une élection en popularité on
est autour des 40%. donc c'est moins que
la majorité c'est beaucoup mieux que ces
prédécesseurs c'est deux fois mieux
François Hollande c'est 10 points de
plus que Nicolas mais
[Musique]
oui enfin en termes de enfin popularité
oui
concernant les résultats du premier tour
il faut bien voir qu'il y a eu ce qu'on
a appelé ce fameux vote utile très
clairement des lecteurs qui devaient
notamment voter par exemple Valérie
Pécresse et qui se sont dit autant voté
Macron tout de suite parce que voyant
que toute façon leur candidate avait
très peu de chance d'arriver au deuxième
tour donc il y a ça qui a joué aussi
plus que plus qu'un effet de popularité
en effet de de votre vraiment utile quoi
c'est à dire puisque notre candidate a
très peu de chances d'arriver au
deuxième tour on vote pour Macron donc
alors il y a eu un front antimacron
enfin on verra en tout cas ils ont oui
sur le Frontier Macron en tous les cas
c'était pas uni c'était c'était
par contre sur le front antimacon
c'était une donnée qui était donnée par
plusieurs politologues et plusieurs
plusieurs institutions de sondages
depuis un an et demi presque deux ans
oui c'est pour ça que c'est compliqué de
parler de popularité de suremmanuel
Macron en fait c'est vous avez un niveau
de popularité c'est-à-dire de gens qui
disent qu'il est un bon président qui
est minoritaire mais qui est bien
meilleur que c'est près des sœurs et
vous avez en revanche un niveau de rejet
de ceux qui ne l'apprécient pas en fait
ils clivent une il ne laisse pas
indifférent Emmanuel Macron il nous il
peut nous rappeler si Nicolas Sarkozy
quand on regarde les traits d'images du
du président il ressemble à s'y
méprendre aux qualités aux défauts qui
étaient prêtés à Nicolas Sarkozy 10 ans
avant lui notamment sur l'aspect
président des riches etc et donc il
suscite une colère très forte de ceux
qui n'apprécient pas mais il a aussi un
socle important de gens qui l'apprécient
et il parvient finalement à se sortir de
je crois que ça fait ça fait une
quinzaine d'années qu'on avait pas un
président qui pouvait aborder une
séquence électorale l'avenir en ayant ce
socle de popularité là
par rapport à ses prédécesseurs c'est
beaucoup mieux Sarkozy avait une vraie
popularité dans le camp à droite et là
Macron elle est où sa vraie popularité
il est où son socle et ben il est au
milieu il est en même temps c'est à dire
que vous avez il arrive à avoir un socle
central de de d'électeurs
socio-démocrates je trouve scanner si
vous voulez de ces courants là au PS
jusque à une droite de gouvernement
raisonnable qui d'ailleurs a largement
déserté le vote élève de gouvernement
raisonnable mais
c'est pas un jugement personnel quand je
dis ça c'est se définissant comme tel si
vous voulez nous voulons pas renverser
la table pas jugement personnel que je
livre sur les uns ou les autres
simplement Emmanuel Macron il est sur
ces fameux deux Français sur 3 que veut
que chercher Giscard c'est-à-dire une
position centrale et il arrive à avoir
un socle qui lui a permis de faire plus
de 25 % au premier tour ça c'est son
socle et puis une quinzaine de points de
plus de gens qui l'apprécient finalement
ça amène à 40 et puis pour les autres et
ben tant pis alors ça mène à 40 mais ça
même pas à 50 ou à plus de 50 ce soir
c'est quand même Guillaume
front contre front républicain contre
front antimacron et quels seront quel
sera le front le plus fort
de ce que à la main qui avait appelé le
cercle de la raison et contre ceux qui
ne se retrouvent pas dans cette dans
cette offre politique entre le cercle de
la colère oui sans doute
cercle de l'inquiétude aussi parce que
ce sont les perdants de la
mondialisation il y avait je reviens à
ce papier de Jérôme Fourquet mais qui
était très intéressant
de le mettre dans le chat on avait il y
avait l'analyse du vote du premier tour
pour Macron ou pour Le Pen en fonction
de la question vivez-vous mieux que vos
parents et tous les gens qui vivaient
mieux que leurs parents votaient Macron
et tous les gens qui avaient le
sentiment de vivre moins bien que leurs
parents votaient le peigne enfin
j'exagère pas tous mais la différence
était extrêmement spectaculaire et c'est
vrai que Manuel Macron est à la fois le
l'acteur et le reflet de cette
désidéologie de la société française
le les vieux clivages droite et gauche
en particulier droite et gauche de
gouvernement ne veulent plus dire grand
chose c'est sans doute une des
conséquences aussi les deux quinquennat
précédent à Nicolas Sarkozy il y avait
fait entrer des gens de gauche de dans
son gouvernement et d'un François
Hollande qui avait fait une loi travail
qui aurait pu être faite par un
gouvernement de centre droit
Marie-Amélie Bocher que nous avons dans
l'oreillette vient de nous dire que dans
15 secondes marre moins de 15 secondes
il était 19h59 on devrait connaître donc
maintenant dans moins d'une minute qui
sera le prochain locataire de l'Elysée
dans les cinq prochaines années Marine
Le Pen va-t-elle prendre sa revanche
Emmanuel Macron est-il reconduit pour 5
ans de plus et bien réponse maintenant
dans un peu plus de 30 secondes mais
guère plus
on va mettre peut-être un compteur
qui est parti même plutôt que plutôt
plus tard que prévu et c'est pas grave
à 30 secondes peut-être je sais pas on
va le voir normalement on va le donner
jusqu'au bout mais de toute façon ça
donnera crédit à la fiabilité des
résultats que l'on va vous annoncer donc
maintenant dans un dans une dizaine de
secondes on est en train de me dire
et c'est donc Emmanuel Macron qui est
réélu avec
58% des voix selon les dernières
estimations contre 42% pour Marine Le
Pen
58% donc pour le président sortant 42
pour la challengeuse donc tu
rassemblement national on va tout de
suite regarder les images en direct
du QG d'Emmanuel Macron donc vous voyez
sur ces images de l'Agence France Presse
les drapeaux
qui se figent
au Champ de Mars effectivement donc
c'est des images pour ni par l'Agence
France Presse où il y a beaucoup de
monde qui viennent de découvrir les
mêmes résultats que nous et les mêmes
premières estimations
de ce second tour
2022 alors également on va avoir les
résultats la réaction en ce moment un
peu de Marine Le Pen
voilà alors la réélection dans un dans
un instant tous les cas les images qui
nous parviennent montrent bien sûr ben
voilà les voilà l'ambiance donc au
quartier général de Marine Le Pen
voilà
et donc
une réaction qui est un petit peu plus
neutre que sur le Champ de Mars on va
essayer de d'avoir nos envoyés spéciaux
tout de suite dès qu'on peut le savoir
alors effectivement
car la connexion est très difficile au
Champ de Mars on retrouvera Matisse
fleuret dans quelques instants mais on
va pouvoir peut-être entendre Daphné
Caravaca qui est au QG de Marine Le Pen
alors avant d'avoir
Daphné Caravaca et Mathis fleuret les
images l'ambiance en ce moment au Champ
de Mars et on réagit aussitôt après
en ce moment au Champ de Mars où va
aller se rendre Emmanuel Macron on va
essayer d'y aller dès que nos connexions
seront rétablies mais il y a
effectivement énormément de monde
en ce moment sur place et tout le monde
étendu plex Anne une première réaction
donc 58% pour Emmanuel Macron ce sont
les premières estimations elles
devraient se confirmer ces premières
estimations il n'y a pas de doute sont
bonnes pour Emmanuel Macron qui une fois
de plus
réussie un défi qui n'était pas évident
la première fois il a été élu il venait
nulle part on le connaissait à peine à
39 ans premier président première élu à
39 ans alors qu'il n'avait jamais eu
d'autres mandats auparavant et là il
réélu donc il se retrouve le quatrième
si on compte enfin on compte pas de goal
puisque de Gaulle a été élu en 58
c'était pas encore le suffrage univers
direct donc troisième président à être
réélu après Mitterrand echirac
donc oui c'est quand même une réussite
on peut après ce qui sera intéressant
c'est que et pour Mitterrand Mitterrand
ça a été suivi il a été élu en 88 il y a
une cohabitation après et
Chirac la cohabitation était avant donc
on va retrouver avant Gaëlle et on a
retrouvé la liaison avec Daphné Caravaca
dans le QG de Marine Le Pen est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer comment ça
s'est passé à l'annonce des résultats
alors à l'annonce des résultats on a pu
voir des visages très déçus comme vous
le voyez sur ces images on a entendu des
personnes huées les résultats et comme
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure avec
Damien qui était avec nous les militants
estiment que ce n'est que partie remise
pour les législatives qui auront lieu
dans un peu plus d'un mois il y a 5 ans
les militants espérés atteindre les 45%
et aujourd'hui c'est encore une
déception
merci beaucoup Daphné un commentaire
Gaëlle oui pour rebondir sur ce que
disait Anne c'est c'est intéressant
d'observer que c'est peut-être même une
première finalement puisque il y avait
une règle dans la vie politique
française qui était que quand vous êtes
au manette quand vous êtes au pouvoir
vous êtes éjecté il y avait un dégagisme
permanent puisqu'il y avait des
législatives avec des cohabitations qui
faisaient que même ceux qui ont été
réélus les deux que vous évoquiez
avaient pu s'appuyer sur une
cohabitation et quelque part il n'était
plus vraiment les sortants dans le cas
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est la première fois
qu'on a quelqu'un qui est élu et le même
qui est réélu et en plus face au même
adversaire et alors on verra les tiages
des estimations si ça se resserre ou si
ça s'accentue ça va bouger un tout petit
peu mais plus beaucoup si on est
symboliquement c'est vraiment très
symbolique au dessus des 58 on reste à
58 à 58 2
il souffrira moins de la comparaison et
de la baisse de 8 points par rapport à
il y a 5 ans et pour Marine Le Pen on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure ça sera assez
compliqué de dire la prochaine fois je
gagnerai elle restera très loin et
l'enjeu c'était vraiment de se
rapprocher des 55 ou descendre en
dessous des 55 pour elle et donc pour
Emmanuel Macron l'inverse et donc c'est
une belle victoire pour Emmanuel Macron
ce soir vous voyez les images en direct
donc du Champ de Mars et Guillaume on
vous a pas entendu par gagner pour
Emmanuel Macron alors votre prédiction
de l'automne c'est vérifié aujourd'hui
j'étais pas le seul donc honnêtement
c'était pas un risque considérable que
je prenais mais ça prouve que le
l'intuition d'Emmanuel Macron
était juste vous savez en 2017 quand il
a été élu lui avait déjà théorisé cette
fin de de la du partage droit de gauche
de gouvernement au profit d'un vaste
centre réformateur et d'autres disaient
mais non c'est parce que François Fillon
avait rien faire qui lui collait au
basque c'est parce que Benoît Hamon
n'était pas le bon candidat pour le
Parti socialiste et bien non là il y a
eu d'autres candidats et le mouvement
c'est approfondi donc on peut dire que
Emmanuel Macron est vraiment un homme
qui a complètement
marqué l'histoire de la Cinquième
République avec cette nouvelle offre
politique et de l'autre côté chez Marine
Le Pen je regardais l'ensemble des
sondages qui ont été faits depuis le 12
mars il y en a eu 42 et bien sûr 42
sondages il y en avait que 4 qui la
mettaient au niveau où elle était
effectivement ce soir tous les autres la
mettaient beaucoup plus haut et donc ça
va être compliqué pour le rassemblement
national parce que je dirais comme en
2017 Marine Le Pen était partie d'assez
haut il y avait même des sondages qu'il
la mettaient 48 52 aucune elle la
mettait gagnante mais mais le match
s'annonçait très serré et finalement il
ne l'est pas c'est sûrement une très
grande déception ce soir pour le
rassemblement national j'ajouterai juste
pour compléter ce que vient de dire
Guillaume c'est que celui qui avait
théorisé
espace central qui a été oublié dans
l'histoire c'était Alain Juppé qui avait
dit qui parlait de l'omelette
debout petite précision pour lui une
victoire pour Alain Juppé pour ceux qui
ont beaucoup parié sur sur cette espace
centrale c'est vrai que cet espace
central avant la victoire d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 hormis le très bon score
de François Bayrou en 2007 il faisait
pas il réalisait pas des scores
extraordinaires
les jeunes diraient c'était à chaque
fois la loose à chaque fois vous partiez
on a eu bar on a eu Bayrou cette ce
projet-là alors on peut peut-être mettre
une parenthèse avec Giscard quand une
fois il avait théorisé cette histoire du
2 français sur trois il venait d'un
centre alors un centre droit voilà mais
en même temps Emmanuel Macron il y a 5
ans il venait d'un centre gauche donc
finalement
mais il a réussi son pari en dynamitant
en explosant complètement la gauche et
la droite la gauche le PS et le l'ex RPR
UMP LR ça a complètement explosé voler
en éclat avec quand même alors c'était
aussi ça le pari qu'il faisait un risque
qui était en le faisant il maximisait
les chances d'avoir pour adversaire une
candidate d'extrême droite
qu'il pensait à juste titre pouvoir plus
facilement battre mais le danger c'est
que c'était lui ou le chaos d'une
certaine manière par pour son électorat
et donc il y avait aussi un enjeu on en
revient aux histoires de 55 ou de 52 ou
de 53 il y avait aussi un enjeu à gagner
relativement nettement pour lui pour ne
pas donner le sentiment que il avait
fait courir un risque pour la partie des
Français qui sont très opposés avoir
l'extrême droite tenir au pouvoir en
France même si Marine Le Pen dit
aujourd'hui qu'elle n'est plus d'extrême
droite et puis elle a gagné quand même
parce qu'elle avait gagné
on a soldat Bertrand dans le chat Figaro
live qui nous dit le comptage au bureau
de vote n'est pas encore terminé et on
donne des résultats peut-être une petite
précision Gaëlle qu'est-ce qu'une
estimation exactement pourquoi on a ces
résultats à 20h est-ce que ce sont des
résultats définitifs oui ça variera très
peu maintenant on avait vécu il y a 15
jours des petites évolutions un peu
inquiétantes pour pour mes confrères qui
qui portaient ses estimations mais ça
varie très très peu les estimations
c'est un échantillon de bureau de vote
donc et de bulletins de vote donc qui
sont tirés et donc ils ne peuvent pas se
soustraire ni à l'interrogation ce sont
des bulletins ni vous mentir et donc
depuis maintenant une quarantaine
d'années vous avez ces systèmes
d'estimation qui permettent de
déterminer grâce au bureau qui ferment
avant les autres et qui sont
échantillonnés pour être représentatif
de l'ensemble des bureaux y compris ceux
qui ferment plus tard et qui sont des
bureaux urbains et qui nous permettent
de savoir donc c'est une technique de
sondage mais on n'interroge plus les
gens on collecte des bulletins et donc
on a plus de crise possible sauf si on
était sur un résultat à 50,1 contre 49,9
ça pourrait bouger encore un tout petit
peu mais là c'est fixé l'incertitude
c'est ce qu'on sera un peu plus de 58
ouais
en ce moment au Champ de Mars c'est
visage triste et fermé au pavillon
d'armenanville au bois de Boulogne d'un
côté chez Emmanuel Macron ici vous le
voyez sur ces images dans le quartier
général de Marine Le Pen ou l'ambiance
est complètement éteinte ici c'est le
quartier général en tous les cas là où
sont réunis les partisans d'Emmanuel
Macron et le podium où il devra prendre
la parole Timothée délai va suivre le
cortège du président depuis l'Élysée dès
que les premières images qui nous sont
ramenées par la moto du Figaro nous
parviendrons on voulait montrera vous
vouliez réagir tout à l'heure Guillaume
oui je repensais à ce score d'Emmanuel
Macron qui effectivement est
relativement spectaculaire et qui peut
être explique parce qu'il l'avait en
tête avec les les derniers sondages la
sonatitude dans le dans le débat
d'entre-deux tours on dit souvent que
passer un certain âge on ne change que
quand on a peur et de toutes évidence il
n'avait pas peur et donc je dirais que
le naturel avait un peu repris le dessus
c'est à dire ce sentiment de supériorité
mais qui n'est pas seulement de
l'arrogance qui n'est pas seulement un
défaut de caractère mais aussi la
conviction d'avoir raison veut dire de
de de d'être celui qui écrit l'histoire
parce que en étant l'homme une seconde
fois qui correspond au centre de gravité
de la vie politique française et à
l'état d'esprit des Français qui est
encore une fois ne veulent plus de cette
de la politique à l'ancienne qui ont
aussi abandonné très largement tout ce
qui pourrait apparaître comme une forme
de
de surplomb
idéologique culturelle le débat d'entre
deux tours c'était un débat très
technique finalement ça aurait pu être
un débat de Premier ministre ils n'ont
pas beaucoup parlé leur vision pour la
France ils n'ont pas parlé de sujets qui
tiennent à cœur une minorité de Français
qui sont les sujets sociétaux les sujets
éthiques non en gros c'est le c'est le
super gestionnaire et c'est aussi
l'homme qui s'engage pour l'Europe ça
c'est important et tous ces choix là ils
ont été validé ce soir et donc
rétrospectivement on comprend le Pen
arrive Marine Le Pen va faire
[Musique]
un grand vent de liberté aurait pu se
lever sur le pays le sort des urnes que
je respecte en a voulu autrement
en dépit de deux semaines de méthodes
déloyale brutale et violente
similaire à celle que subit ce quotidien
les Français les idées que nous
représentons arrivent à des sommets un
soir de second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
avec plus de 43% des voix le résultat de
ce soir représente en lui-même une
éclatante victoire
des millions de nos compatriotes ont
fait le choix du camp national et du
changement
j'adresse ainsi ma plus profonde
gratitude à tous ceux qui m'ont fait
confiance au premier tour et tous ceux
qui parmi million nous ont rejoint au
second
mais remerciements vont tout
particulièrement à nos compatriotes des
provinces et des campagnes mais
également d'outre-mer qui m'ont
qui m'ont largement placé en tête du
second tour avec une force
extraordinaire qui meurt et me touche
sincèrement cette France
cette France trompe oubliée nous nous ne
l'oublions pas
déterminez nous le sommes plus que
jamais et notre volonté de dépenser
encore renforcé je n'ai aujourd'hui
aucun ressentiment ni rancoeur
enterré nous l'avons été mille fois et
mille fois l'histoire a donné tort à
ceux qui prévoyaient ou espérait notre
disparition dans cette défaite je ne
peux m'empêcher de sentir une forme
d'espérance
ce résultat constitue pour nos
dirigeants français
le témoignage d'une grande défiance du
peuple français à leur égard qu'ils ne
peuvent-ils et celui de l'aspiration
largement partagée d'un grand changement
les Français manifestent ce soir le
souhait d'un contre-pouvoir fort à celui
d'Emmanuel Macron
tout liberté face à la remise en cause
de nos services publics et de notre
système social face au recul premier par
Emmanuel Macron de l'âge de la retraite
face à l'insécurité à l'immigration
anarchique et au laxisme judiciaire en
effet je crains ce soir que le
quinquennat qui s'ouvre ne rompre pas
avec les pratiques méprisantes et
brutales du précédent et qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne fera rien pour réparer les
fractures qui divisent notre pays et
font souffrir nos compatriotes alors oui
pour éviter cet accaparement des
pouvoirs par quelques-uns plus que
jamais je poursuivrai mon engagement
pour la France et les Français avec
l'énergie la persévérance et l'affection
que vous me connaissez
[Musique]
de cette séquence présidentielle une
grande recomposition politique se fait
jour dans le pays avec l'effacement des
parties autrefois dominants et
l'affirmation face aux élites
autoproclamés d'Emmanuel Macron du
courant national comme véritable
opposition la partie n'est pas tout à
fait jouée puisque dans quelques
semaines en effet auront lieu les
élections législatives
avec le mode de scrutin législatif qui
renforce les tendances politiques et on
le sait fausse la représentativité
parlementaire le risque de voir Emmanuel
Macron s'emparer de manière mécanique de
tous les pouvoirs exécutifs et
législatif est élevé c'est une
perspective coquin patriote qu'aucun
démocrate ne peut accepter tant le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron sur le régalien
ou le social reste clivant et pour la
France destructeur face à ceux qui
prétendent demain être l'opposition à
Emmanuel Macron et qui ont pourtant
contribué à le réélire nous serons ceux
nous serons seuls qui avec une sincérité
intacte ne transiseront pas avec vos
intérêts par conséquent nous lançons ce
soir la grande bataille électorale des
législatives
je mènerai cette bataille aux côtés de
Jordan Bardella avec tous ceux qui ont
eu le courage de s'opposer à Emmanuel
Macron second tour bref avec tous ceux
qui ont la nation cheville au corps le
rassemblement national œuvrera à unir
tout ce dont ils viennent qui veulent se
rassembler et rassembler leur force
contre la politique d'Emmanuel Macron
afin de présenter ou de soutenir des
candidats partout et donc dans votre
circonscription en métropole en
outre-mer et dans les circonscriptions
de l'étranger je vous invite d'ores et
déjà à les appuyer de toutes vos forces
et dès le 12 juin à voter pour eux
rappelez-vous mes amis qu'il n'y a pas
de fatalité quand les Français déjous
les pronostics continuent de garder
espoir et nous donne les moyens de les
défendre le score historique de ce soir
place notre camp dans d'excellentes
dispositions pour obtenir un grand
nombre de députés en juin prochain
la passion de l'avenir qui nous anime
nous voulons la mettre au service de la
plus belle ambition qui soit de la Somme
ambition qui vaille et que je suis sûr
vous partager avec nous la France ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
ce soir je le redis jamais je
n'abandonnerai les Français vive la
République vive la France
[Applaudissements]
allons enfants voilà donc la première
réaction première déclaration de Marine
Le Pen discours de défaite à 20h15 4
minutes de discours
on sent qu'elle a du mal à encaisser sa
défaite Anne oui puis elle enjolive un
petit peu quand même la réalité parce
que éclatant de victoire même si elle a
progressé par rapport à son score
précédent parle de score historique ce
qui est intéressant oui elle a du mal et
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'elle a
deux reprises elle a parlé des méthodes
déloyale et brutales elle utilise le mot
brutal pour Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs
c'est un en général la qualificatif
qu'on utilise pour pour parler du
rassemblement national ou en tout cas de
nécessaire le Front national bon puis là
maintenant il est dans la bataille des
législatives tout à fait logiquement
mais
cela dit pour revenir au débat de
l'autre jour on a senti par moment
durant le débat que
il y avait presque comme le désarroi
dans ce regard qui avait dans le regard
de son père quand il a appris qu'il
était au deuxième tour il y a eu
quelques passages comme ça ou finalement
alors qu'on a toujours dit que Marine Le
Pen elle voulait le pouvoir finalement
en regardant ce débat la dernière fois
je me suis posé la question est-ce
qu'elle le voulait vraiment elle a dit
aussi qu'elle poursuivrait la bataille
et est-ce que ça c'était attendu ou pas
et bien pendant toute une séquence
d'avant le premier tour Marine Le Pen
avait dit si je ne suis pas élu ce sera
en tout cas ma dernière candidature et
puis voilà maintenant trois semaines
qu'elle même un mois qu'elle ne le dit
plus qu'elle laisse entendre que elle
pourrait rester dans la compétition
présidentielle et elle a eu c'est
effectivement ces deux phrases
importantes ce soir je poursuivrai mon
engagement et en toute fin de ce bref
discours jamais je n'abandonnerai les
Français donc c'est un élément clé on
peut comprendre qu'elle ait changé
d'avis rappelons que en 2012 elle
faisait 19% des voix elle n'est pas à
l'époque qualifiée pour le second tour
en 2017 elle est qualifiée pour le
second tour et elle fait 33 là elle fait
42 elle se dit peut-être que les courbes
vont se prolonger en tout cas cette
décision si elle devait se confirmer
puisque c'est pas une annonce officielle
évidemment on n'est pas candidat à une
élection de l'an 5 ans le soir d'une
défaite mais si effectivement Marine Le
Pen reste à la tête de son mouvement
alors ça peut changer beaucoup de choses
notamment pour tous ceux qui chez les
républicains ou dans le camp d'Éric
Zemmour rêvait d'un abandon de la vie
politique de Marine Le Pen pour
reconfigurer à leur profit la droite ou
les droites
oui elle est dans une situation un petit
peu ambiguë elle choisit d'ailleurs pour
information les estimations qui la
rapprochent le plus du 57 que celle qui
sont à 58
elle est elle est dans une situation
tout à fait compliquée parce que
s'agissant de ne pas dire qu'elle va
raccrocher les gants tout de suite c'est
normal il y a la bataille des
législatives elle ne peut pas faire une
jasma oui elle ne peut pas faire une
Jospin entre guillemets c'est à dire
j'ose pas du 21 avril il y a 20 ans qui
dit avec beaucoup de dignité qu'il
quittent la vie politique française mais
qui laisse son camp en plan pardon alors
on va nous dire quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est prêt mais on va le prendre d'une
minute à l'autre Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
futur Premier ministre le cas il a
candidaté alors c'est curieux d'ailleurs
je pensais à Jean-Luc Mélenchon puisque
il s'est lui aussi projeté sur sur la
bataille des législatives comme Marine
Le Pen et comme Marine Le Pen il avait
dit lui aussi qu'il arrêterait la vie
politique française que c'était sa
dernière campagne et on ne l'entend plus
le dire non plus depuis quelques
semaines on va peut-être l'entendre
parce que là il est en train de parler
est-ce qu'on a Jean-Luc Mélenchon
d'un choix biaisé
il surnage dans un océan d'abstention
de bulletin blanc et nul
ma pensée se tourne vers les futurs
victimes de cette situation
les personnes qui vivent du RSA et
devront travailler gratuitement pendant
20 heures
les personnes
usées qui partiront à la retraite trois
ans plus tard
les personnes prises à la gorge
financièrement et qui ne verront pas les
prix être bloqués
les personnes qui savent à quel point
l'inaction écologique de Monsieur Macron
est un crime
les personnes qui voient avec tristesse
l'état détruit
et le pays vendu à la découpe
à toutes et à tous je dis ne vous
résignez pas
au contraire
entrer dans l'action
franchement massivement
la démocratie peut nous donner de
nouveau le moyen de changer de cap
le troisième tour commence ce soir
les 12 et 19 juin ont lieu les élections
législatives
vous pouvez battre monsieur Macron et
choisir un autre chemin
le 12 et 19 juin un autre monde est
encore possible si vous élisez une
majorité je dis bien une majorité de
députés de la nouvelle union populaire
qui doit s'élargir
le Bloc populaire qui sait constitué
autour de ma candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
est dans ce pays dorénavant le tiers
état qui peut tout changer s'il sera
semble et s'il
le 12 et 19 juin
on vous appelant Amélie comme Premier
ministre
je vous appelle en vérité à faire vivre
un nouvel avenir en commun pour notre
peuple
courage action
détermination
refusent toujours de la fatalité et de
la résignation
vive la France vive la république
alors là ce qu'on a quand même pas une
bataille pour l'opposition vulcaining
des prises de parole Guillaume oui sans
doute on a aussi un Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui apparaît beaucoup moins volontaire
qui ne l'était au soir du premier tour
c'est vrai qu'il avait fait un beau
score mais objectivement pour lui ce
score élevé d'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas
une bonne nouvelle parce que tout son
ton tout son pari en disant je serai le
premier ministre c'était de dire je
représente l'aspiration d'une majorité
de Français c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué à faire entendre au pays avec
un président de la République réélu si
c'est le cas avec une aussi confortable
majorité ce qui est étonnant aussi c'est
la prudence de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on
sait que il y a des des appels du pied
qui sont faits aux autres parties de
gauche pour essayer de de les faire
partir ensemble et éviter la dispersion
des candidatures là est-ce que c'est
parce qu'il est sonné est-ce que c'est
passé considère que c'est pas le moment
de le dire en tout cas je trouve presque
presque
éteint ce soir c'est peut-être juste le
fait que cette il est surpris par ce
résultat ça a peut-être pas de sens
politique mais on ne voit pas le
Emmanuel Macron le Jean-Luc Mélenchon
conquérant appelé à prendre la tête de
l'opposition voir d'une nouvelle
majorité il a également déclaré que
Macron était donc le président le plus
mal élu de la Cinquième République et il
a démarré aussi son son intervention
disant qu'il avait été élu dans un océan
de bulletin blanc et nul Gaël slimann
est-ce qu'on sait à peu près déjà
comment a voté l'électorat de Mélenchon
alors on sait on sait juste première
première chose pourquoi Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dit ça et à quoi il fait
allusion est-ce que ça signifie
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le score dont
l'un des deux en l'occurrence Emmanuel
Macron qui qui pourrait avoir en
intégrant l'abstention et les votes
blancs et nuls en disant que ce serait
un peu plus d'un tiers précisément on
est à 38% des lecteurs
ont voté Macron 27% qui ont voté Marine
Le Pen les autres se sont absolus ont
voté blanc une île il y a un précédent
mais qui était celui qu'on évoquait il y
a un instant je crois que c'est Anne
fullda qui en parlait le précédent de
bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet le duel
power Pompidou c'est le seul précédent
où on est parvenu à avoir un président
moins bien élu on était à 37 et demi
mais le cas de figure est tellement
différent puisque l'offre politique
était la même en fait entre les deux
candidats qu'en réalité ça signifie
qu'il y a bien cette fragilité chez
Emmanuel Macron et que derrière le score
de 57 ou 58% qui est donné par les
estimations actuellement et bien il y a
largement en trompe l'oeil l'idée que
beaucoup de Français ne s'y retrouvent
pas c'est parce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
le sait que Marine Le Pen le sait aussi
qu'ils essayent l'un et l'autre de
prendre le mistigri de l'opposition et
de parler législative mais ça va être
très compliqué parce que d'habitude ce
qui se passe c'est quelle que soit
d'ailleurs le président élu c'est un
vote de confirmation et ce sont des
parties L1 et l'autre qui sont des
partis qui ont du mal au législatives si
ça s'était joué entre Emmanuel Macron et
Valérie Pécresse par exemple ou Emmanuel
Macron et Annie dalgo là il y aurait
peut-être une possibilité pour le
perdant au soir de du second tour de
mobiliser son camp parce que ce sont des
partis qui sont habitués à faire des
scores législatifs avoir des équipes des
armées des contingents qui peuvent leur
permettre de peser dans le cas de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le Pen ce sera
difficile et puis dernier point et on
est on est sur deux opposants au
président sur des offres politiques qui
peuvent converger sur certains points
mais qui globalement sont quand même
très différentes et qui sont à peu près
du même poids si on regarde le poids de
premier tour ça aussi c'est un atout
pour Macron une difficulté et pour l'un
et pour l'autre
est-ce qu'on n'a pas une configuration
finalement aujourd'hui c'est un peu un
retour vers le futur qui était celle de
la Quatrième République avec un parti
communiste fort un parti gaulliste fort
et puis on avait une tendance un parti
central qui était très divisé très
morcelé mais finalement qui arrivait à
s'en sortir parce que justement le RPF
d'un côté et le PC de l'autre on
n'arrivait pas à le suivre oui alors
c'est étonnant comme comparaison parce
qu'on est vraiment sur des institutions
complètement différentes et que et qu'il
n'y avait aucune personnalité forte dans
ses époques guimolay sur le sur la
Quatrième République là vous avez
quelqu'un qui a tous les pouvoirs qui
probablement sauf énorme surprise c'est
ce sur quoi Paris c'est le pari de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de et de Marine Le
Pen sauf énorme surprise il aura
probablement une confirmation lors des
législatives c'est le sens de l'histoire
avec le problème que qu'évoque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et qui est Marine Le Pen aussi
et qui est exact à voir finalement 37 ou
38 % de Français qui même au second
tuyau dit c'est lui que je veux et
pouvoir gouverner pour 10 ans avec des
pouvoirs considérables il est 20h30 je
vous rappelle donc les résultats en tout
cas les premières estimations de ce
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
le président sortant est réélu avec 58
pour l'instant 58% des suffrages contre
42 pour la candidate du Rassemblement
National Marine Le Pen vous voyez sur
donc les dernières estimations qui
s'affichent en direct à l'écran on va
retrouver tout de suite notre reporter
notre journaliste Timothée d'Hélène qui
est sur la moto sur une moto et qui donc
logiquement se dirige vers le Champ de
Mars vers le lieu de victoire d'Emmanuel
Macron Timothée est-ce que la liaison
fonctionne est-ce qu'on vous a
oui brune je vous entends très bien je
suis effectivement sur les Champs
Elysées actuellement vous le voyez ici
l'avenue Marini qui arrive donc sur la
Place Beauvau au fond et l'Elysée juste
à côté on a ici la place de la Concorde
dans le fond et ici donc l'avenue
Clemenceau et ici beaucoup de motos
comme vous pouvez le voir des motos de
des chaînes de télévision des confrères
donc qui sont en train d'attendre le
cortège d'Emmanuel Macron qui devrait
arriver d'ici quelques minutes et ici
vous le voyez beaucoup de camions enfin
un camion de pompier deux camions de
secours en face de moi j'essaye de vous
montrer cela au mieux sur ces images il
y a eu un carambolage un
sacré-coremballage il y a une dizaine de
minutes de cela une voiture qui est
arrivée alors de l'avenue de Marigny ou
bien des Champs-Élysées et qui c'est
donc pris dans le dans le trottoir que
vous voyez juste devant moi là on voit
quelques traces elle est rentrée en fait
dans le trottoir il y a un attroupement
sur ce trottoir avec une un piéton qui
aurait et qui a été touché par la
voiture qui a perdu totalement le
chauffeur qui a perdu totalement le
contrôle de sa voiture et qui à terme
qui a traversé les champs et qui s'est
retrouvé de l'autre côté une personne
est en réanimation en train d'être
réanimé depuis tout à l'heure les
secours qui viennent d'arriver il y a
quelques minutes on ignore la raison
pour laquelle cette personne a perdu le
contrôle de son véhicule est-ce que elle
regardait et bien le cortège de moto
est-ce que c'est une autre raison pour
l'instant en tout cas nous ne savons pas
mais voilà les secours qui qui arrivent
depuis quelques minutes pour réanimer
semble-t-il une personne dans sa voiture
la voiture qui est dans le qui est
totalement rentré dans le trottoir là
si Timothée on vous retrouve tout à
l'heure et à l'instant le ministre
allemand des Finances qui réagissent ce
soir le plus grand vainqueur de
l'élection en France c'est l'Europe vive
la France live l'Europe en dit-il dans
le texte dit Alexander Christiane linner
le ministre allemand des Finances
bonsoir Guillaume Tabar
plus moins de 55% pour Macron c'était
décevant mais plus de 55% c'est le
risque que Mélenchon lui fasse peser la
légitimité de sa victoire c'est en clair
la thèse de votre dernier contrepoint là
on n'a pas vu un Mélenchon triomphant
donc de quoi c'est 58% sont le nom selon
vous alors le résultat quand même plus
plus élevé que ce que prenait promettait
les sondages en fin de en fait campagne
est très nette très large et on se
souvient déjà qu'en 2017 malgré une
victoire encore plus nette Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avait mis en cause en doute la
légitimité d'Emmanuel Macron il a
retenté de le faire ce soir en disant
que Emmanuel Macron était le président
le plus mal élu de tous les de tous les
présidents c'est vrai qu'en termes de
par rapport aux inscrits je crois qu'on
est à peu près à 38% des inscrits ce qui
est fait enfin il y a bien des
présidents qui ont été élus avec un
score assez assez voisin entre 38 et 40%
des inscrits donc c'est pas ça en soi
qui est le plus le plus le plus
significatif la comparer et large elle
est inférieure à celle qui était il y a
il y a 5 ans la passation est elle-même
sensiblement moins forte donc oui il y a
moins de
moins d'élan qu'il y a 5 ans et surtout
il y a 5 ans il avait été élu en
incarnant la nouveauté on incarnant le
renouveau on incarnant la volonté et le
crédit pour faire quelque chose de
clairement inédit dans la vie politique
française là il est le sortant et il a
bénéficié d'un vote utile on a entendu
tout à l'heure c'est Golan Royal le si
le dire à sa manière il a bénéficié de
la vote utile anti Le Pen de ce point de
vue là sa campagne de second tour qui je
pense à manquer de clarté idéologique à
au moins viser l'efficacité électorale
et de ce point de vue là il a remporté
son pari qui était de d'attirer le
maximum de voix de de réveiller
l'épouvantail le penis sera droite entre
les deux tours ça a marché donc ça lui
donnait cette a permis ce score mais
quelque part ça lui rend les choses
encore plus difficiles pour gouverner
parce que maintenant pour gouverner il
faut acquise clairement ce qu'il fait il
y en a qui ont entendu qu'il voulait
faire la retraite à 65 ans il y en a qui
ont entendu et c'est ce qu'il a
tireusement autour que ça fait pas sa
priorité qu'on pouvait quand même
négocier sur l'âge il y en a entendu
qu'il voulait lutter contre le
communautarisme comme il l'a fait avec
sa loi pendant de président il y en a
d'autres qui ont entendu et c'est ceux
qui la rallié pendant l'entre-deux tours
à Saint-Denis exalté cette fabuleuse
diversité et se voile qui dans certains
cas pouvait même incarner le féminisme
vous voyez dans ce souci d'efficacité
électorale d'ordre de Tours je pense
qu'il y a eu des repères idéologiques
d'identité politique ont été brouillées
et c'est maintenant qu'Emmanuel Macron
va devoir restaurer une forme de clarté
dans son action
on va peut-être entendre Éric Zemmour
d'un instant à l'autre en tous les cas
il est
la liaison il se prépare à parler on
écoutera bien entendu quand il parlera
moi je voulais juste savoir du coup
est-ce que c'est le Front républicain
qui a fonctionné est-ce que c'est un
vote d'adhésion au programme de Macron
ou est-ce que c'est clairement le vote
utile enfin du coup
s'opposaient l'un à l'autre c'est-à-dire
que Emmanuel Macron n'a pas tant cherché
à entraîner sur son projet il a cherché
entre nez pour dire ah il faut
absolument éviter Marine Le Pen parce
que ça République en danger et
symétriquement Marine Le Pen n'a pas
tant cherché à convaincre que son
programme était le était le meilleur et
de ce point de vue là le débat restera
aussi comme un moment difficile peu pour
elle elle aura simplement chercher à
dire débarrassez-vous de Macron en
votant pour moi donc on avait deux
fronts négatifs l'un contre l'autre bah
il y a des deux fronts qui étaient plus
fort que l'autre le Front républicain
fonctionne encore je sais pas si on peut
l'appeler le Front républicain parce que
il se transforme en voiture
c'est Guillaume avait raison de rappeler
cette cette expression qui est utilisée
par la main je pense que c'est plutôt ça
qui a été choisi effectivement terre qui
a un parc il y avait un pari risqué à
choisir Marine Le Pen que oui c'est
beaucoup des lecteurs n'ont pas on
choisit de ne pas prendre oui c'était
sans doute cet élément qu'on regardait
dans les dans les bilans de
il peut se débat etc il y avait un
certain équilibre on peut pas dire que
Macron est eu spécialement plus
d'adhésion que Marine Le Pen dans les
sondages qu'on a pu réaliser sur leur
image respective en revanche il inspiré
moins peur juste pour rebondir sur les
motivations du vote on avait quand même
pas loin de 40 % des lecteurs qui nous
disaient à peu près à parité je vais
voter avant tout pour faire barrage à
l'un ou à l'autre alors ça pouvait
varier de quelques points d'une vague
d'enquête à l'autre mais c'est assez
équilibré et ça c'est quand même un très
grand changement y compris par rapport à
2017 ou déjà l'idée de front républicain
c'était érodé cette fois-ci il n'existe
plus vraiment c'est pas tellement la
peur de des idées politiques habituelles
de l'extrême droite qui a dissuadé
certains électeurs de voter pour elle
probablement c'est davantage l'idée que
on sort du covid qu'on vient d'avoir la
guerre en Ukraine et que ce serait une
aventure sans doute dangereuse pour le
pays que de confier les clés à Marine Le
Pen alors qu'avec Emmanuel Macron on
sait ce qu'on a vous le voyez l'ancien
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe qui
est arrivé au Champ de Mars et qui fait
pareil comme l'ont fait d'autres
ministres des selfies et un bain de
foule avec les partisans d'Emmanuel
Macron Guillaume peut-être Guillaume
Rocket une question sur cette
polarisation dont on parle depuis le
début de la soirée sur la base de ce cas
de l'étude de gerameur Fourquet publié
jeudi dernier dans le Figaro est-ce que
ce vote aussi c'est pas l'échec de ce
que Jérôme Sainte-Marie appelé le Bloc
populaire et la victoire d'un autre bloc
dont on dit que il n'est pas
représentatif mais enfin ça représente
57% ce soir le bloc aitaire absolument
quand vous gagnez les élections vous
êtes forcément représentatif sinon c'est
qu'on ne croit plus dans la dans la
démocratie en tout cas vous êtes
représentatif du plus grand nombre de
Français je pense que la limite de de la
théorie de notre ami Jérôme Sainte Marie
c'est que les secteur de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aussi représentait assez
largement des classes populaires et cela
Mélenchon les a appelés si ce n'est
expressément à voter pour Emmanuel
Macron en tout cas à faire barage à
Marine Le Pen et quand on dit le Bloc
populaire si on raisonne uniquement avec
les gens on va dire les conditions les
plus modestes et bien il y en a une
grande partie qui vote Le Pen ceux qui
se sentent déclassés abandonnés ce qui
ne reconnaissent plus leur pays mais
vous avez aussi des des classes
populaires notamment
issues de l'immigration qui elle se
tournent vers Emmanuel Macron et
Guillaume tabard le rappelait à
l'instant le président sortant leur a
lancé un certain nombre de d'appels du
pied ce n'est pas un hasard si une de
ces dernières manifestations publiques a
été une visite à Saint-Denis c'était
jeudi dernier pourtant il y a pas
beaucoup de
la Seine-Saint-Denis a été un des lieux
où il y a eu le plus abstention quand
même aujourd'hui ce sont les dernières
estimations oui mais
très très élevé je crois autour de 50%
des premiers tours pour pour Jean-Luc
Jean-Luc Mélenchon voilà on n'a pas je
pense encore les résultats des votes en
Seine-Saint-Denis ce qu'on sait c'est
que dans les départements d'outre-mer ou
c'est l'autre zone où on était très fort
il y avait frôler les a même dépassé les
50% premier tour
dans le 10 avril c'est Marine Le Pen qui
est sorti même assez largement
et la soirée et ce qui fait que lorsque
ces résultats outre-mer sont tombés à
mi-journées parce que c'est ça qui
circulait à mi-journée certains ont
imaginé ou pensé ou cru ou redoutées ou
espérer que ça allait annoncer un
résultat plus serré que prévu on voit
bien qu'il y avait une forme d'exception
ultramarine si on peut dire faut avoir
ce qui s'est passé en Seine-Saint-Denis
sera intéressant pour comprendre comment
ces comporter le lecteur adjoint
Mélenchon sur base de ce que dit
certains instituts qui commencent à
faire des ventilations bon en gros on
aurait quand même
à la louche la moitié des acteurs de
Mélenchon quand est voté Macron un quart
que révolté pour Marine Le Pen et un
quart qui sera obtenu alors un ou deux
pour cent prêt mais voilà ça donne un
peu le et on était sur une tendance
plutôt à beaucoup plus délicate juste
après le premier tour c'est-à-dire qu'on
était sur du 30/2050 30 Macron 20 Le Pen
en moyenne à peu près et 50 %
d'abstention de votre blanc nul et là il
semblerait qu'on soit plutôt sur un sur
deux et un quart un quart ça veut dire
qu'il y a une mobilisation quand même
sur la fin on se disant c'est quand même
Marine Le Pen en face on va voter contre
pour ces électorat là le ministère de
l'Intérieur a vient de donner du coup
les chiffres justement dans les Antilles
et en Guyane donc elle remporte la
Guadeloupe à soit plus de 69% des
suffrages 60,87% en Martinique et 60,70
en Guyane et plus de 54% à Saint-Barth
également donc c'est c'est des scores
qui sont 4 millions de personnes
et si on compare par rapport au score du
premier tour dans ce département
selon les départements concernés même
Marine Le Pen a progressé de 40 à 50
points et absolument colossal là
Emmanuel Macron a progressé entre 20 et
25 points dans ces dans ces départements
d'outre-mer que le lecteur a
mélangentiste sur place en tout cas
c'est sans doute plus reporté son Marine
Le Pen mais une fois encore c'est il y
avait aussi tout le débat face au vaccin
qui a du je pense peser beaucoup dans
ces départements on va regarder ça et on
va écouter Éric Zemmour qui est en train
de prendre la parole
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire ce soir ma déception et ma
tristesse
bien que nous ayons été des millions à
vouloir en finir avec le quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron ce soir les amoureux
de la France ont perdu et Emmanuel
Macron a été réélu aisément
il est le premier président à avoir été
réélu sans sortir d'une période de
cohabitation et alors même que sa
personne faisait l'objet d'un rejet
massif par nos compatriotes
son duel avec Marine Le Pen était
présentée comme la revanche de celui de
2017 mais la revanche annonçait à
tourner court
cela fait trop longtemps que ceux qui
aiment passionnément la France sont
vaincus cela fait trop longtemps que
ceux qui veulent défendre son identité
et mettre un terme à l'immigration sont
amèrement déçus un soir d'élection
hélas hélas hélas c'est la huitième fois
que la défaite frappe le nom de Le Pen
je voyais cette défaite venir depuis des
années et ce n'est vraiment pas de
gaieté de cœur que je l'annonçais j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu pour éviter ce
résultat je me suis engagé pour cela je
n'y suis pas parvenu
en appelant sans tergiverser dès le soir
du premier tour à voter pour Marine Le
Pen je priais encore
pour me tromper
malheureusement pour la France
malheureusement pour les Français c'est
bien Emmanuel Macron qui a été élu
sommes-nous donc condamnés à perdre y
a-t-il une fatalité pour que les idées
nationales perdent toutes les élections
alors qu'une majorité de notre peuple
souhaite ardemment que la France reste
la France
non je veux dire ce soir qu'il n'y a pas
de fatalité nous avons des raisons
d'espérer
notre partie reconquête effort de cette
jeunesse cette belle jeunesse militante
et si enthousiaste
[Applaudissements]
parti reconquête est fort de ses 122
000 adhérents et je remercie ceux qui
continuent de nous rejoindre chaque jour
il est fort de ces milliers de cadres
partout en France fort de ses talents de
sa créativité de ses compétences nous
serons donc à la pointe du combat pour
lutter pieds à pied contre l'oeuvre de
déconstruction de notre pays mené par
Emmanuel Macron nous combattrons pour
nos idées dans chaque ville et dans
chaque village de France sur internet et
dans les médias
mais il ne peut y avoir de victoire
électorales sans alliance entre toutes
les droites entre les classes populaires
et la bourgeoisie patriote entre les
grands-parents et leurs petits-enfants
entre la France périphérique et les
habitants des métropoles qu'ils veulent
continuer de vivre dans une France
française
là si tu as Sion politique d'aujourd'hui
nous impose d'agir les élections
législatives qui viennent en juin
prochain voient déjà la constitution de
deux grands blocs politiques autour
d'Emmanuel Macron et de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon deux blocs l'un macroniste
l'autre islamo gauchiste deux blocs qui
s'organisent se rassemblent et s'apprête
à s'affronter dans un match qui n'aura à
court sur qu'un seul perdant la France
le camp national serait-il donc le seul
à ne pas être capable de s'unir
voulons-nous donner les pleins pouvoirs
à Emmanuel Macron et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
je ne le veux pas nous sommes des
millions à ne pas le vouloir le Bloc
national doit lui aussi s'unir et se
rassembler notre responsabilité est
immense
c'est pour cela que j'appelle à l'Union
nationale en vue des législatives
nous devons oublier nos querelles et
unir nos forces c'est possible c'est
indispensable c'est notre devoir
bâtissons au plus vite la première
coalition des droites et des patriotes
pour que les élus de reconquête du
rassemblement national de Debout la
France et ceux des républicains qui ne
veulent pas se rallier à Emmanuel Macron
est une chance de peser voir de dominer
dans la prochaine assemblée
notre coalition n'est pas une option
elle est une nécessité elle est un
devoir nous avons un pays à reconquérir
l'union fait la force notre coalition
doit faire la France vive la république
et surtout surtout vive la France
donc
Eric Zemmour le candidat de reconquête
qui avait recueilli 7% au premier tour
peut-être un commentaire Gaëlle sur ce
qu'il faut
décrypter derrière ce discours en termes
dans tous les cas de dynamique
électorale oui mais en terme de
stratégie pour ce qu'on appelle appeler
l'extrême droite c'est c'est le score de
ce soir permet Éric Zemmour ce type de
discours effectivement il a très
clairement dit au soir du premier tour
sans aucune ambiguïté qu'il appelait à
voter Marine Le Pen effectivement avant
cela il avait dit que s'il constitue son
parti reconquête c'est parce qu'il
estimait qu'elle n'avait aucune chance
de l'emporter et que ce qui se passe ce
soir il l'avait anticipé il l'avait dit
répéter et donc il ne perd pas une
minute voyant que le score est quand
même une défaite importante de Marine Le
Pen 57 58 il se sent pleinement investi
et légitime pour parler de cette union
et expliquer que la stratégie de Marine
Le Pen qui consiste à dire je ne suis ni
d'extrême droite ni même de droite je
suis au dessus c'est parti c'était ça sa
ligne pour essayer de récupérer des
électeurs pourquoi pas qu'il y avait
voté Jean-Luc Mélenchon cette stratégie
là n'a pas fonctionné et Eric Zemmour se
saisit de cet échec parce que 57 58
c'est le signe d'un échec pour pouvoir
remonter à la charge et proposer ce que
Marion maréchal souhaite depuis des
années ce que lui-même le message dont
il était porteur en créant en reconquête
c'est une stratégie totalement
différente de celle de Marine Le Pen qui
avait refusé toute discussion avec
reconquête au soir du du premier tour et
donc ça c'est possible parce que la
défaite des Marine Le Pen est large si
on avait été sur 53 ou 54% et bien il
aurait eu plus de mal à avancer cet
argument là le problème c'est que Éric
Zemmour lui-même a fait 7 % au premier
tour et c'est ça qui est étonnant le
la situation pourrait Emmanuel Macron
est extraordinairement favorable le
Parti socialiste n'existe plus le LR a
fait moins de 5 LRF a fait moins de 5
une partie de LR a déjà pris parti pour
Emmanuel Macron derrière Nicolas Sarkozy
il est très probable qu'une que d'autres
vont suivre d'ici les législatives et
Marcel morencé par exemple la présidente
de la région Pays de la Loire qui vient
de faire un communiqué pour dire qu'il
fallait maintenant travailler avec le
président et donner les moyens d'agir et
Marine Le Pen quand elle a une belle
défaite mais une défaite qu'on voulait
se commenter mais on va mettre tout de
suite les images en direct de Timothée
d'elem ça ça bouge du côté de la moto on
va regarder tout de suite
donc le cortège est parti Timothée
apparemment
il peut pas répondre il conduits
le président de la République qui se
trouve à quelques mètres de nous je vous
le disais
et donc je sais pas si vous m'entendez
beaucoup de bruit on voit la voiture
avec le président de la République qui
se trouve dans cette voiture là
voilà on était en train de
s'approcher des Invalides est-ce que
vous m'entendez Vincent
on voit bien que en tous les cas il y a
la le véhicule du Président vous prenez
pas trop de risques et effectivement on
suit le on suit le convoi avec vous donc
il va prendre la direction apparemment
du Champ de Mars et on continue à suivre
les images et on revient vers vous
vous êtes pas les seuls donc vous faites
attention à vous prudence Guillaume
on vous a coupé
je disais que il y a ce soir une double
victoire d'Emmanuel Macron d'abord une
victoire électorale
puisqueman nous disait tout à l'heure et
Éric Zemmour le constatait lui aussi
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la République est réélu sans être
passé par une période de d'opposition de
fait à travers une cohabitation mais
c'est aussi une victoire par chaos
puisque tous les autres partis
politiques aujourd'hui sont sont
fragilisés et effectivement les
législatives s'annoncent passionnantes
parce que est-ce qu'il va y avoir à
nouveau ce réflexe légitimiste qui a
classiquement
l'élection des députés qui suivent
l'assemblée l'élection présidentielle ou
les électeurs choisissent en toute
cohérence de donner une majorité au
président qui viennent des lire avec des
oppositions qui sont plus morcelées que
jamais
objectivement Emmanuel Macron a beaucoup
de cartes dans sa dans sa main ce soir
et puis je pense à renversement du
paysage politique et que personne
n'avait pour être franc imaginé avant
cette élection une certaine manière le
point fixe Emmanuel Macron qui est réélu
mais souvenez-vous il y a encore un mois
d'abord on pointait du fait que le du
doigt que la France était
majoritairement à droite et ce qui se
passait il y avait marine le penca
reparti en campagne il y avait Éric
Zemmour qui crée quelque chose il y
avait la droite qui réussit ses sa
primaire donc il se passe des choses à
droite et on disait la gauche elle est
moribonde c'est les claquements c'est
l'éparpillement c'est les nettement donc
tout le monde prenait acte du fait que
la gauche était morte et qui se passait
des choses à droite au terme de cette
élection on voit que la droite est plus
fracturée que jamais même moribonde que
jamais elle a l'air est en du seuil de
flottaison il y a également on a
toujours dit pas les moyens d'être
maître de l'Alliance et inversement on a
vu un Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui avec toutes
sortes de de de
d'artifice ou de Sarah a réussi à se
poser en pôles fédérateur de la gauche
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le courant qui
incarne une opposition en tout cas qui
va exister au législative face Emmanuel
Macron c'est pendant une opposition de
gauche autour de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
pas une opposition de droite hormis ce
que pourrait faire Marine Le Pen mais ça
on le verra dans pendant ces élections
un commentaire peut-être sur le sujet
il a appelé à ce quoi il avait appelé
auparavant ce qui était tout à fait
logique ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant je trouve c'est le défi qui
a le président réélu face à ce paysage
politique
redessiné fragmenté et avec ce qu'on
évoquait au début c'est-à-dire le taux
d'abstention extrêmement important les
bulletins blancs et nuls extrêmement
important donc cette espèce de
désaveu quand même de la politique telle
qu'elle est menée aujourd'hui de
désintérêt et là il a un champ énorme
devant lui on va retourner sur le
la moto la moto de Timothée Timothée le
cortège s'est arrêté devant Matignon
oui Vincent alors il y a beaucoup de
bruit si je n'ai pas entendu votre
question Vincent vous avez vu le cortège
qui s'est animé et en fait nous avons
suivi Jean Castex qui est donc parti de
l'Elysée où il se trouvait il a rejoint
Matignon nous nous sommes donc tous
arrêtés devant en Matignon il y avait
plusieurs dizaines je dirais une
vingtaine de
motos de journalistes de confrères et là
vous l'entendez nous sommes en train et
bien de retourner
[Musique]
le score en élan pour un deuxième mandat
parce que ce qui est clair c'est que cet
élan il n'est pas apparu durant sa
campagne ni le premier tour ni de ni de
second tour est-ce que ce petit bonus
électoral va lui permettre maintenant
d'embrayer et de créer un élan pour
mener un second
d'action et paniquement un quinquennat
pour pour durer et versement Marine Le
Pen faut pas oublier qu'il y a 5 ans
elle passe de 37 % au second tour de la
prise en selle à 13% pour son parti au
législative et la capacité d'avoir un
groupe à l'Assemblée est-ce que cette
fois-ci forte de cette progression par
rapport à 5 ans elle sera capable de
structurer une opposition de droite
autour d'elle et une position de droite
représentée suffisamment Parlement c'est
c'est un défi pour elle on suivra ça
dans vos commentaires et justement dans
les commentaires de la carte électorale
Guillaume avec impatience Anne un mode
conclusion
de conclusion c'est quand même une
victoire de Macron qui quand même nous
surprend pour la deuxième fois il faut
bien dire et on attend le troisième tour
de présidentielle avec ses législatives
et ce qui serait intéressant
effectivement c'est de voir qui
incarnera l'opposition au pouvoir en
place
une victoire très claire d'Emmanuel
Macron mais avec ce trompe l'oeil qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure juste avant
votre arrivée sur la part des lecteurs
qui ont positivement voté pour lui à ce
second tour autour de 38 39 % qui est
faible donc il va falloir que moi je
pense qu'il est bien parti pour les
législatives compte tenu tout ce qu'on
s'est dit précédemment il va falloir
penser contre lui-même être capable de
gouverner en sachant que au-delà d'une
victoire très nette sur cette
présidentielle et probablement d'une
situation favorable aussi à l'issue des
législatives une partie du pays de la
pas suivi et qu'il faudra qu'il leur
montre qu'il pense à eux et qu'il ne
gouverne pas sans eux parce que sinon
c'est pas un troisième tour qui va se
passer c'est un quatrième cet automne et
il sera social
[Musique]
historiquement très spécifique du
général de Gaulle il y a eu deux
présidents réélu pour un deuxième mandat
François Mitterrand Jacques Chirac dans
les deux cas
ça a été deux secondes mandat
d'innaction pour aller vite la question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans la tête
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il veut
rester comme ces deux prédécesseurs
comme étant l'homme qui a essayé de
réunir les Français qui a essayé d'être
plutôt dans la Concorde quitte à ne pas
trop les les bousculer ou bien est-ce
que le Macron de 2017 est toujours là
celui qui voulait bouleverser la France
pour l'émanciper l'avantage pour la
réformer on n'a pas encore la réponse à
ça cette campagne de second tour elle a
été très flou Guillaume Tabar le
rappelait d'un point de vue
programmatique donc est-ce que ça
n'était qu'un leur est-ce qu'on va voir
revenir le Macron conquérant et
réformateur ou au contraire un homme
plus consensuel ce sera le l'enjeu de ce
deuxième mandat
merci beaucoup on va se quitter sur ces
images ah ben elles ont disparu mais
elles vont réapparaître peut-être de
nous avoir en ce moment Timothée
d'Hélène donc en plein Paris direction
du Champ de Mars et sa santé
effectivement la place de l'Alma en tous
les cas il y a du cortège dans l'air on
va retrouver tout de suite Maxime Laurie
qui va nous faire un petit point sur les
dernières infos et les derniers chiffres
c'est à vous
tous revenons d'abord sur les dernières
prises de parole suite aux résultats de
cette sélection présidentielle c'est la
huitième fois que la défaite frappe le
nom de Le Pen je voyais cette défaite
venir depuis des années ce sont les mots
d'Éric Zemmour qui vient de s'exprimer
juste à l'instant en réaction résultat
de cette élection il a également appelé
à l'Union nationale pour les
législatives à venir poursuivons ce
point info avec les réactions de la
gauche dont plusieurs responsables
politiques ont pris la parole au cours
des dernières minutes d'abord
l'ex-candidat Écologie Les Verts Yannick
Jadot a estimé que le pire était évité
mais que le pays était plus divisé que
jamais une autre ancienne candidate à la
présidence Ségolène Royal a considéré
elle que les Français avaient été
privées d'un vrai choix sur cette
élection même si elle a tenu à féliciter
Emmanuel Macron de façon faire play une
bien moins enthousiaste Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a lui affirmé que Monsieur
Macron était le président le plus mal
élu des présidents de la 5e République
le troisième homme de cette élection
présidentielle en a profité lui aussi
pour lancer sa campagne pour les
législatives et indiquer que l'union
politique populaire pardon devait
s'élargir pour Marine Le Pen le résultat
de ce soir représente en lui-même une
éclatante victoire je poursuivrai mon
engagement pour la France et les
Français a-t-elle dit juste après
l'annonce des résultats depuis son QG au
Pavillon d'harmononville Marine Le Pen
qui devrait être candidate dans le
Pas-de-Calais les 12 et 19 juin prochain
selon le président du Rassemblement
national Jordan Bardella on attend
désormais le discours du président Ré
qui devrait se rendre au Champ de Mars
d'ici quelques minutes pour prendre la
parole devant plusieurs centaines de
sympathisants et de journalistes le
cortège suivi par Timothée délai est
parti au moment où je vous parle côté la
République en marche le porte-parole du
gouvernement Gabriel Attal accueille sur
les résultats avec reconnaissance et
responsabilité Bruno Le Maire à lui
saluer un choix clair des Français à
l'international le président du Conseil
européen Charles Michel et la présidente
de la Commission européenne
Ursula van der Leyen on fait partie des
premiers à féliciter Emmanuel Macron
pour cette réélection ensemble nous
ferons avancer la France et l'Europe à
Twitter Ursula Vander leion revenons
enfin sur les scores de ce soir selon
les dernières estimations ephop
fiduciales publiées à 20h le président
Emmanuel Macron est réélu avec 58% des
voix contre 42% pour Marine Le Pen très
net victoire victoire historique
remontada les qualificatifs sont
nombreux pour décrire la réaction
d'Emmanuel Macron ce soir il est en
effet le premier président hors période
de cohabitation depuis le début de la
cinquième République
coup Maxime Lorie on va tout de suite
écouter une interview qui a été
enregistrée par notre équipe qui était
sur le Champ de Mars qui est toujours
sur le Champ de Mars mais qui a des
problèmes de connexion pour envoyer un
direct elle était tout à l'heure avec un
militant la République en marche on
l'écoute
je suis avec Max et Antonin donc
militants qui sont venus ici pour
célébrer la victoire d'Emmanuel Macron
tout simplement quel est votre première
réaction ici après les résultats
alors moi je suis tout d'abord très
soulagé parce que mine de rien les
sondages étaient quand même plutôt
serrés et puis on a vu que les sondages
n'étaient pas forcément fidèle donc
première réaction j'irai très soulagée
et fier que Macron soyez le président
alors on vous a un peu extirpé de la
foule et de l'ambiance là-bas c'est quoi
votre programme après pour la soirée
voilà on compte sur la fête c'est vrai
qu'on est venu on habite juste à côté
donc on a entendu la musique et puis on
voulait venir voilà à côté donc c'est
vraiment super nous on veut vraiment
attendre surtout Emmanuel Macron
l'entendre parler en tant que son
discours d'après peut-être faire la fête
on verra mais bon demain il faut être
sérieux quand même tu es sorti en boîte
peut-être on sait pas
on va regarder les images
au Champ de Mars il vient d'arriver le
président le cortège présidentiel vient
donc d'arriver ou en tout cas étant
passe d'arrivée sur le lieu de victoire
du président réélu
Timothée
oui Bruno vient d'arriver on vient
d'arriver au Champ de Mars
voilà Jean Castex qui vient de passer à
l'instant devant nos yeux et là on voit
les voitures des officiels qui sont en
train et bien de passer devant nous on
est à l'arrêt la voiture d'Emmanuel
Macron se trouve parmi les voitures que
vous voyez en train d'arriver ça ça ne
fait absolument aucun doute Jean
castexte le Premier ministre vient donc
de passer devant nos yeux et donc
beaucoup beaucoup de journalistes comme
vous le voyez ici j'essaye de vous
montrer cela au maximum tout le monde
attend l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron il y
a également vous allez le voir derrière
ces vannes ou vitres teintées et
difficiles de de percevoir qui est à
l'intérieur évidemment beaucoup de
policiers et vous le voyez ici également
beaucoup et bien de Parisiens et
parisienne qui sont là pour voir
l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron un important
dispositif également policier vous le
voyez ces policiers qui sont là et qui
donc
voiture de passer juste derrière nous et
vous le voyez donc les voitures des
officielles qui sont en train de
s'avancer vers le Champ de Mars je vous
le disais Jean Castex vient de nous
passer devant Emmanuel Macron lui se
trouve peut-être à bord de l'une de ces
voitures aux vitres teintées
en tout cas beaucoup d'animations ici
merci beaucoup et ben vous nous tenez au
courant et pendant ce temps-là on va
retourner peut-être dans un instant voir
Mathis fleuret mais on va profiter pour
vous présenter notre nouveau plateau
honneur aux dames honneur Adam Véronique
reissous vous êtes donc directrice au
fondatrice de backbone Consulting
bienvenue et côté odoxa c'est Céline
vous présentez Céline braque l'actrice
générale les co-fondatrice de doxa à
côté de moi leur salvader actrice
générale de cantar public bonsoir Laure
et enfin Guillaume Bernard bonsoir vous
êtes politologue maître de conférence à
lissesse et également auteur d'un d'un
livre la guerre de la droite aura bien
lieu la guerre à droite pardon bonsoir à
tous
la précision alors peut-être une
première une première réaction Céline
braque à ses résultats est-ce que
finalement les sondages avaient raison
la tendance a été là c'est à dire que
c'est bien le président de la République
qui a été réélu et ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'on a vu finalement un tout un
électorat qui se posait beaucoup de
questions sur s'abstenir ou pas pour ce
second tour et je pense en particulier à
l'électorat de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
était très hésitant et qui a priori
c'est ce que semble montrer les premiers
sondages qui ont été faits aujourd'hui
ce serait majoritairement aurait
majoritairement voté Emmanuel Macron
alors on peut pas encore dire si ce sont
les mêmes qui la semaine dernière ont
voté pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui sont
absolument revenus c'est exactement dans
ses proportions là mais ce sont les
premières tendances et finalement un
quart pour Marine Le Pen un quart qui
aurait décidé finalement s'abstenir ce
qui fait que ça a basculé assez
largement quand même en faveur
d'Emmanuel Macron sachant que les
électeurs de Valérie Pécresse ce sont
très largement
choisies Emmanuel Macron ainsi que les
électeurs des deux candidats de gauche à
nidalgo et et Yannick Jadot c'est les
tendances que vous avez également oui
oui tout à fait alors moi ce qui me
marque dans les dans les tendances
actuelles c'est notamment ces électeurs
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de premier tour
qui aujourd'hui vote à 17% qui ont voté
aujourd'hui à 17% pour Marine Le Pen
alors qu'il n'était que 7% en 2017 donc
la sociologie de ces électeurs de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est en train d'être
modifié à changer la deuxième chose moi
qui me marque dans ces résultats et ce
sont les premières données que nous
avons les plus jeunes les 18-24 ans et
les plus âgés les 70 ans et plus sont
ceux qui ont le plus voté Emmanuel
Macron donc quand on parle de
extrême droitisation de la jeunesse ou
en fait c'est plutôt les
34 ans dont on parle mais les 18-24 il y
a quand même un noyau dur qui qui vote
pour en tout cas qui ont voté là pour le
candidat centriste et puis un dernier
élément qui qui nous marque dans ces
résultats finalement quand on se remet
sur la base des inscrits Emmanuel Macron
vous le disait fait partie des
présidents qui a été le plus mal élu au
global il ne représente finalement que
38,1% des inscrits et ça je pense que
c'est important à avoir en tête pour la
suite et notamment dans le cadre de la
campagne et les élections législatives
Guillaume est-ce que
encore une fois cette pas la mise en
échec d'une théorie pourtant que vous
avez défendu qui était le mouvement
d'extrogyre c'est un mouvement qui
pousse la société vers la droite et ben
non chers Vincent je ne le crois pas il
suffit tout simplement de regarder les
résultats de ce soir parce que
évidemment Emmanuel Macron l'a emporté
il n'empêche qu'il l'a emporté avec 58%
alors qu'il l'avait emporté avec 66% la
dernière fois que Marine Le Pen a fait
42% au lieu de 34 et que elle a gagné
2,5 millions de voix par rapport à 2017
donc moi je veux bien qu'effectivement
le choix ce soir et parfaitement plié il
n'empêche que Marine Le Pen a progressé
et qu'elle fait 2 millions et demi de
voix de plus que il y a 5 ans et que
Emmanuel Macron ça vient d'être dit je
suis parfaitement d'accord avec ça et
d'un des présidents les moins bien élus
de la Cinquième République 38% des
inscrits alors qu'il avait eu 43% des
inscrits en 2017 donc il y a pas eu tant
de blanc que ça et de nul comme on
pouvait l'imaginer il y en a eu moins
que lors de la dernière élection mais
une abstention très forte qui aboutit à
ce résultat en effet y a t-il un des
internautes sur Le Figaro.fr qui nous
dit qu'il réagit à ce que ce que vous
dites si Macron était si mauvais il
n'aurait pas été élu deux fois de suite
quand même non moi je n'ai pas dit
absolument pas dit qu'il était pas élu
j'ai dit simplement que
après un premier après un premier
mandat présidentiel François Mitterrand
certes après une période de cohabitation
et réélu avec un score supérieur avec
celui qu'il avait obtenu en 1981 bon la
réélection Jacques Chirac en 2002 c'est
un cas effectivement un petit peu
particulier
évidemment il fait beaucoup plus que ce
qu'il avait fait en 1995 mais là pour le
coup Emmanuel Macron est réélu s'est
absolument raconté ça mais il est élu en
faisant un score inférieur à celui qui
l'avait obtenu il y a 5 ans c'est tout
ce que je constate et ceci dit c'est
vrai que c'est c'est c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire compte tenu de
toute la période que qu'il a pu vivre
les gilets jaunes la crise covid la
guerre du crâne il est quand même plutôt
bien élu finalement compte tenu du
contexte
que j'aurais bien aimé vous faire
commenter parce que nous venons de voir
Manuel Valls et François Bayrou côte à
côte ce soir sur
le Champ de Mars c'est la grande
coalition
je suis parfaitement d'accord avec vous
mais cela dit alors si vous voulez que
je rentre dans le dans l'analyse un peu
plus précise je dirais des des résultats
du camp qui a été au second tour face à
Emmanuel Macron il est bien évident que
les 42%
on verra si ça change un petit peu en
fin de soirée mais enfin les grosso modo
les 42% de de Marine Le Pen c'est le
score le plus mauvais si j'ose dire pour
qu'il puisse y avoir une recomposition
de la droite pourquoi parce que si elle
avait fait moins de 40 elle aurait été
totalement décrédibilisée
euh si elle avait fait plus de 45 elle
se serait effectivement imposé comme
étant la seule susceptible de pouvoir
s'opposer je dirais à la grande
coalition macronienne là elle est entre
les deux et donc par conséquent elle
peut être effectivement
disputer discuter quant à sa légitimité
pour continuer à incarner le camp le le
camp de la droite nationale ou de la
droite radicale
pour autant pour autant évidemment elle
pèse trois fois plus que Éric Zemmour le
plateau précédent Lady je crois que
c'est Guillaume roquette qui en a parlé
elle pèse trois fois plus Carric Zemmour
et donc par conséquent il est bien
évident que lui avait prédit qu'elle ne
pourrait pas gagner c'est un fait mais
pour autant elle pèse trois fois plus
que lui donc dans la recomposition de ce
bloc politique là ben il y a évidemment
images un instant donc on était tourné
par nos équipes
sur place juste après le discours de de
Marine Le Pen
un regard justement peut-être Céline sur
la
le score de Marine Le Pen je suis
d'accord avec Guillaume c'est avec la
difficulté maintenant c'est qui pour
discuter à Marine Le Pen son titre de
championne de la droite radicale parce
que là on ne voit pas très très bien et
c'est vrai que sa nièce alors sa nièce
qui a une cote certaine auprès des
sympathisants de droite a fait sans
doute le mauvais choix stratégique en
allant en allant entre guillemets trahir
sa tante à la à la veille de du premier
tour ou à l'avant veille du premier tour
et ça rend en tout cas un petit moment
le son rôle à elle un petit peu
difficile bon après en politique les
histoires sont souvent un peu longues on
se trahit et puis on se réunit et donc
il laisserait tout à fait possible par
exemple que Marion maréchal reprenne le
flambeau après sa tante mais le discours
de Marine Le Pen était quand même assez
vindicatif et il est pas sûr qu'elle
malgré qu'elle a pu dire précédemment
elle est elle lâche elle lâche le gant
[Musique]
ne soit pas suffisant donc voilà après
est-ce que c'est un programme ouf je ne
suis pas certaine donc maintenant le
débat va être qu'elles vont nous faire
demain et on voit d'ailleurs ce soir
dans les images du Champ de Mars et les
commentaires qui peut y avoir sur les
réseaux que on n'est pas alors de
nouveau dans des mots assez clés valises
des mots pointus un dimensions d'un bon
Bosch voilà qui est l'autre mot utilisé
finalement il y a pas une ambiance
hydrague on sert on attend le Président
on attend son discours qui devrait
galvaniser quand même les quelques
personnes qui sont sur Mars mais ça
n'est pas la même histoire que que pour
la première fois on n'a pas ces images
fortes de ce jeune homme plein de
promesses il y a 5 ans donc c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose mais il est
évident que c'est un peu plus festif de
ce côté là alors je sais pas si c'est un
si vous le voyez sur ces images en
direct du Champ de Mars Jean cast
ex c'est pas à l'instant mais on nos
équipes nous le signalent nos équipes
sur place
il était donc dans le cortège que vous
avez vu précédemment qui a été fini par
les parties d'Hélène timetedem qui a
priori est reparti vers l'Elysée car
dans ce cortège que nous avions filmé il
n'y avait que le premier ministre et le
président était toujours à l'Elysée donc
il est reparti pour le faire vivre en
direct son arrivée aussi qui monte c'est
combien de temps monsieur Castel va
faire l'intérim qui est le nouveau
gouvernement donc un petit jeu qui est
en train de se passer sur les réseaux
avec des noms qui circulent qui en sera
qui n'en sera pas c'est la même les
sondeur ne peut rien il faut s'appeler
Emmanuel Macron il doit faire l'intérim
jusqu'au législatif puisque il faut
attendre de savoir quelle sera la
couleur de de cette nouvelle assemblée
pour nommer le nouveau Premier ministre
on va aller sur le Champ de Mars
justement où se trouve Mathis fleuret
qui était avec une militante et on
revient juste après en
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous espérez pour pour la
suite pour ce prochain quinquennat moi
j'espère internationale que tu l'as
donné alors je trouve qu'il a déjà fait
un bon travail le son son dernier
quinquennat mais la crise du covid elle
a ralenti un peu et je pense que avec
les 5 ans qui vont arriver ça ira mieux
je pense
la prochaine étape c'est les
législatives est-ce que vous êtes un peu
inquiète
peut-être oui parce que l'extrême droite
a quand même un bon support et ça peut
faire peur oui je pense merci beaucoup
Clémentine pour cette première prise de
parole ici au QG d'Emmanuel Macron sur
le Champ de Mars
merci merci beaucoup Mathis c'était une
interview donc comme vous l'avez vu
enregistrer précédemment puisqu'on a des
soucis de connexion il faisait jour au
chant de mars j'ai juste avant de lancer
une réaction à plateau donc Valérie
Pécresse qui a réagi la candidatellaire
à la présidentielle elle a félicité le
président Emmanuel Macron pour sa
réélection mais c'est inquiétée d'un
score inédit du rassemblement national
elle a déclaré j'adresse mes
félicitations républicaines à Emmanuel
Macron voyez le tweet s'affiche dans un
tweet cependant donc la victoire ne doit
pas masquer les fractures de notre pays
conduisant Marine Le Pen à un score
inédit et elle appelle désormais à se
concentrer sur les législatives
justement qui auront lieu je vous le
rappelle le 12 et 19 juin prochain on va
y revenir largement dans la soirée mais
les perspectives pour la République pour
les législatives dans ces conditions là
avec ce score ce soir alors
c'est compliqué je pense que on en parle
déjà depuis 15 jours effectivement il y
a des recompositions des tractations il
y a pas mal de
citoyens français aussi y compris de la
République en marche qui aimeraient
qu'il y ait justement des des alliances
avec le centre droit avec d'autres
personnalités je crois que les Français
aspirent à beaucoup d'union aussi en ce
moment que ce soit à gauche ou à droite
donc on va plus forcément parler des
républicains des socialistes etc on est
certainement en train de vivre une
transformation globale de du paysage
politique qu'on a finalement jamais vécu
depuis de nombreuses années
en France voilà donc les républicains ça
va être très compliqué mais ce sont pas
les seuls qui ont des recompositions à
faire dans leur partie en tous les cas
est-ce que l'explosion des républicains
dont on parle dans tous les cas dans
menace qui pèse sur eux depuis le début
de cette campagne
maintenant est inéluctable Guillaume moi
il me semble que oui dans la mesure où
il y a un certain nombre de
personnalités DLR qui ont des sièges à
sauver en particulier à l'Assemblée
nationale mais pas qu'elle a semblée
nationale au Sénat aussi et le
renouvellement ne va pas trop tarder et
donc par conséquent il est vraisemblable
qu'il y a un certain nombre de personnes
qui vont sinon adhérer directement à la
République en marche du moins essayer de
trouver un accord pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de candidat contre eux ou de candidats
trop crédibles contre eux cela dit il y
a quand même à l'intérieur de LR un
certain nombre de personnes alors bon
moi les noms que l'on m'a donné je veux
bien les répéter ici mais enfin sans
garantie totale le rend Wauquiez Éric
Ciotti
Julien Aubert bon voilà ils espèrent
pouvoir essayer de maintenir à flot LR
de telle manière que il puisse continuer
à exister s'appuyer sur le fait il y
avait quand même un certain nombre de
collectivités qu'il y a un certain
nombre de collectivités territoriales
qui sont dirigés par leurs parties il y
a le président qui apparemment est sur
le perron on retrouve tout de suite ce
Timothée d'Hélène
et bien donc que c'est ces personnalités
là essaie de maintenir à fond leur
partie en se disant que il pourrait
peut-être recyfonner et bien une partie
de reconquête du parti des règles
Zemmour voilà est-ce que c'est quelque
chose de de réaliste ou non ça me paraît
effectivement peu probable étant donné
qu'il y a quand même une aspiration de
la part des Français un renouvellement
je dirais de du personnel politique et
des étiquettes politiques mais enfin il
y a une partie des gens de l'air qui
espère
maintenir leur existence
par ce biais là possible elle leur
petite chance quand même c'est le temps
qui va s'écouler entre maintenant et les
législatives qui est inhabituellement
long qui fait que c'est tout un temps où
quand même le gouvernement va devoir un
peu agir peut-être commencer à un peu
mécontenter les Français et il faut y
avoir à Paris que les oppositions
qu'elles soient de gauche ou de droite
vont utiliser ce temps là pour pouvoir
critiquer le critiquer l'exécutif ça
c'est certain maintenant la logique sera
quand même que normalement enfin comme
on est en quinquennat que avec ce
quinquennat que la il y ait une majorité
pour une majorité de la République en
marche qui qui soit là pour soutenir le
président de la République et qui va
poser un problème parce que globalement
aujourd'hui si vous regardez comment les
gens s'expriment sur le sujet des
déchets législatives c'est pas de savoir
s'il est LR vont aller bien c'est pas de
savoir si Monsieur Jadot va avoir des
élus c'est la proportionnelle et il y a
quelque chose qui est en train de monter
très fortement qui est et bien oui ce
soir Marine Le Pen n'a pas fait n'est
pas présidente elle n'a pas fait un
score que qui à la hauteur de leurs
attentes mais elle représente plusieurs
millions de Français et donc la question
que les gens se posent c'est plus quel
est le nombre de députés que le
rassemblement national va avoir quel est
le nombre de députés que la France a
soumise va avoir parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui on a vraiment trois blocs et
ces trois blocs et bien les électeurs de
la France insoumise et du rassemblement
nation ne comprendrait pas ou en tout
cas trouverait extrêmement injuste de ne
pas être présenté dans ce
proportionnelle et donc ça va des
colères relativement fortes et ce soir
c'est déjà ce que l'on peut lire avec
une forme d'incompréhension en disant
mais pourquoi le système n'a pas été
changé avant et en tout cas le sentiment
que voilà une chambre qui ne va pas
représenter la réalité de l'électro je
vous rappelle qu'en 2017 il y avait
moins de la moitié de l'électorat qui
s'était déplacée pour voter au
législatives donc s'il y avait eu un bon
incroyable de l'abstention 15 17 points
d'abstention entre le premier et le
second tour et du coup de nouveau et
très clairement parce que là c'est vrai
qu'on a vu une abstention assez forte
pour la présidentielle mais ce qu'on
avait vu en 2017 c'était une abstention
qui commençait déjà à être forte pour la
présidentielle mais qui était
extrêmement forte législative des
élections qui étaient de qui sont
devenues des élections où notamment les
jeunes électeurs ne se déplacent plus du
tout pour voter pour les députés donc
c'est vrai qu'à il va falloir là aussi
que les institutions peut-être puissent
un petit peu mieux coller à l'électorat
pour que pour remobiliser les pour
remobiliser les forces vous évoquez la
colère dans les urnes il y a également
la colère dans la rue en tout cas nos
confrères de Reuters relèvent en fait
des manifestations qui ont été
dispersées avec du gaz lacrymogène donc
ce soir à Châtelet donc des jeunes
manifestants comme c'est relatés dans
cette dépêche qui s'était réunie à
Châtelet pour protester contre
l'élection ou la plutôt la réélection
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à de nombreuses
manifestations avec cette victoire du
président de la République en tout cas
en juger le nombre de policiers qui
avaient dans Paris je pense qu'on n'est
pas les seuls à se poser cette question
et quand on regarde la colère qui a sur
les réseaux oui les Français ont besoin
de l'exprimer et ont besoin et attendent
un geste alors peut-être qu'on aura ce
soir ou dans les jours qui viennent mais
un geste qui explique que on va
effectivement peut-être un peu adapté
en réalité mode de fonctionnement
pour être adapté avec l'électorat et les
attentes pas forcément tout changer mais
quelques signes qui permettraient de
dire bon les choses sont un peu écouté
et ça calmera un peu et on se sent je
pense qu'il y a vraiment un nouvel
acteur sur la scène politique française
ce sont justement les citoyens et la
contestation citoyenne c'est-à-dire que
le principal opposant aujourd'hui à
Emmanuel Macron c'est pas tant Marine Le
Pen que finalement les citoyens
eux-mêmes et tous les citoyens qui ne se
retrouvent pas dans ces résultats de
second tour et qui ne se retrouvaient
pas déjà dans ce duel entre Emmanuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen donc il ne
voulait pas d'ailleurs il y a quand même
un paradoxe on regarde ces images là
effectivement là c'est un plan serré
puisque c'est plutôt les officiels que
l'on voit et effectivement toutes les
nuances du centre droit et du centre
gauche de François Patriat a François
Bayrou avec au milieu Édouard Philippe
en attendant Emmanuel Macron qui était
donc au dernière nouvelle mais enfin il
a fait quand même
57% ou 58 ou 58% on n'a jamais vu un
président lors de la 5e République
depuis de Gaulle réélu avec un tel score
et surtout après une situation pareille
et un contexte pareil j'ai un autre
personnage justement dont on n'a pas
parlé c'est Édouard Philippe qu'on voit
la au centre et je pense que dans les
prochaines semaines et dans les
prochains mois lui va beaucoup compter
aussi que ce soit du côté des
républicains en tout cas de la grande
droite disons mais c'est ça fait partie
des personnalités qui sont attendues par
les Français dans notre baromètre Figaro
Magazine pour vous que nous réalisons
avec epoka va justement c'est vraiment
la personnalité préférée des Français et
celle sur qui on compte pour l'avenir de
la France et qui a des atouts d'ailleurs
qui sont complémentaires au président de
la République puisque il est jugé par
les Français aussi plus sympathiques
plus proche des gens moins méprisant
quelqu'un me disait mais on s'en fiche
un peu cette histoire de mépris c'est
pas le fait d'être méprisant d'avoir un
caractère comme ça mais ça induit l'idée
que il comprendrait pas bien son peuple
ce qui est un sujet aux yeux des gens et
donc Édouard Philippe pourrait peut-être
s'il est se mettait plus en avant s'il
était un peu au plus au côté du
président de la République est un atout
d'ailleurs le mépris dans ta fait preuve
Emmanuel Macron est forcément
joué contre lui ça sera peut-être une
deuxième question à aborder ensemble à
après le Point Info de Maxime Laurie si
Vincent les messages de soutien
continuent de tomber pour Emmanuel
Macron dont on attend toujours le
discours au Champ de Mars le dernier en
date est celui d'Anne Hidalgo qui a
adressé ses félicitations républicaines
à Monsieur Macron la mère PS de Paris a
souligné que l'extrême droite n'a jamais
été aussi proche du pouvoir notre pays
est fracturé il ne pourra se réunir que
dans la justice sociale à ajouter les
lieux socialistes
Valérie Pécresse elle aussi publié sur
Twitter
il y a peu j'adresse mes félicitations
Emmanuel Macron mais sa victoire ne doit
pas masquer les fractures de notre pays
conduisant Marine Le Pen un score inédit
face à la réaction du président le
candidat communiste Fabien Roussel à lui
appeler ce soir à un accord global de la
gauche pour les législatives afin
d'éviter toute division et aller
ensemble à la conquête d'une majorité de
députés de l'autre côté de la Manche
c'est Boris Johnson Premier ministre
britannique qui vient tout juste de se
dire heureux de continuer avec à
travailler pardon avec le président avec
le président réélu toujours à
l'international le chef du gouvernement
italien Mario Draghi a souligné que la
victoire d'Emmanuel Macron à la
présidentielle représentait une
magnifique nouvelle pour toute l'Europe
une réaction tout à fait différente de
celle d'Eric Zemmour qui s'est aussi
exprimé il y a une petite trentaine de
minutes c'est la huitième fois que la
défaite frappe le nom de Le Pen je
voyais cette défaite venir depuis des
années a dit l'ex-candidat en réaction
aux résultats de cette élection
présidentielle il a également appelé à
l'Union nationale pour les législatives
ce qu'on appelle auquel a répondu le
président du Rassemblement national
Jordan Bardella en promettant que le
parti ne s'enfermerait pas dans une
alliance avec reconquête les 12 et 19
juin prochain sur un ton similaire
Jean-Luc Mélenchon affirmé que Monsieur
Macron était le président le plus mal
élu des présidents de la 5e République
le 3e homme de cette élection
présidentielle en a profité lui aussi
pour lancer sa campagne pour les
législatives et indiquer que l'Union
Populaire devait s'élargir Marine Le Pen
elle aussi s'est exprimée tout à l'heure
le résultat de ce soir représente en
lui-même une éclatante victoire selon
ses mots je poursuivrai mon engagement
pour la France et les Français a-t-elle
dit après l'annonce des résultats depuis
son QG au Pavillon d'Armenonville Marine
Le Pen qui devrait être candidate dans
le Pas-de-Calais pour les législatives
les 12 et 19 juin prochain revenons
enfin sur les scores de ce soir selon
les dernières estimations fiduciales
publiées à 20h le président réélu a
obtenu 58% des voix contre 42% pour
Marine Le Pen un autre score à prendre
en compte ce soir c'est bien sur celui
de l'abstention s'élève à 28,2% pour ce
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
soit presque trois points de plus qu'en
merci Maxime Laury on vous retrouve dans
une demi-heure pour un nouveau point
info et à Stéphane Martel sur le chat du
Figaro life sur Youtube qui nous demande
quand est-ce que parle Macron on ne le
sait pas encore très bien en tout cas et
visiblement il est toujours à l'Élysée
d'après les informations qu'on a de
Timothée délème qui suit son cortège on
vous prévient dès qu'il dès qu'il
rejoint le Champ de Mars et qu'il est
sur le point de parler Guillaume Bernard
peut-être une question sur sur l'union
des droites que prône encore Zemmour et
qui a appelé de ses vœux Éric Zemmour
lors de son discours c'était sa
stratégie pendant toute la
présidentielle c'est à nouveau sa
stratégie pour les législatives est-ce
que pour les législatives ça a plus de
chance d'aboutir que pour la
présidentielle pour une raison
financière la réponse est non parce que
les partis politiques ont intérêt à être
présent sous leur propre couleur au
premier tour des législatives puisque
c'est le nombre de voix que vous obtenez
au premier tour des législatives qui
permet d'obtenir la dotation
financière publique donc par conséquent
je vois mal
leur assemblement national par exemple
trouver un accord avec reconquête alors
cédant des circonscriptions
ce qui signifierait aussi c'est des CD
vous pouvez
vous pouvez regarder
le président pardon justement Emmanuel
Macron qui est en train d'arriver mais
on va vous redonner la parole voilà donc
peut-être on va laisser vivre ces images
même si elles sont au loin
déambulation un peu lointaine et de nuit
et de nuit à pied
de nuit parce qu'évidemment ça crée une
ambiance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
à toi
merci
[Musique]
merci à toi
merci à tous et toutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc on a suivi en direct
l'arrivée de d'Emmanuel Macron que on
continue de suivre en images plein pot
ici avec nous peut-être un premier
commentaire sur ce que on vient de voir
Céline oui alors on a vu une
déambulation qui a été qui était tenté
de solennité voire même de gravité le
visage de de Brigitte Macron était
particulièrement grave
bon je pense que il s'agit là pour le
président de la République pour son
épouse de pas non plus montrer une
espèce de joie triomphante qui serait
peut-être mal venue pour tous les
électeurs qui se sont abstenus ou ceux
qui ont voté un peu par défaut pour lui
il était entouré d'enfants ce qui
tranchait par rapport à 2017 où on
voyait plutôt un homme seul enfin on
voyait complètement un homme seul qui
qui prenait le pouvoir là il y a
certainement l'idée d'incarner
[Musique]
cette idée de l'ensemble
et le fait d'utiliser la musique de
l'hymne à la joie de Beethoven qui est
entre guillemets le l'hymne de l'Union
européenne
merci chers amis
[Applaudissements]
chers compatriotes
ici à Paris
et partout à travers le territoire en
hexagone dans nos outre-mer comme à
l'étranger
oui avant toute chose merci
après
5 années
de transformation d'heures heureuses et
difficiles de crise exceptionnelle aussi
ce jour
du 24 avril 2022 une majorité d'entre
nous a fait le choix de me faire
confiance pour présider notre République
durant les cinq années à venir
[Applaudissements]
alors je veux remercier l'ensemble des
militants des volontaires
des compagnons de route élus qui depuis
le début m'accompagne et ont rendu cette
élection possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais que vous n'avez pas ménagé vos
efforts avait donné tant d'énergie
partagée tant de conviction
c'est en frappant au coeur que vient la
vérité merci et je sais ce que je vous
dois
merci
[Applaudissements]
je remercie
l'ensemble des Françaises des Français
qui au premier puis au deuxième tour
mon accordé leur confiance afin de faire
advenir notre projet pour une France
plus indépendante une Europe plus forte
et par des investissements et des
changements profonds continuez d'assurer
des progrès concrets pour chacun en
libérant la créativité
l'innovation dans notre pays et pour
faire de la France une grande nation
écologique
[Applaudissements]
je sais aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
et je veux ici
les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote m'oblige pour les
années à venir
je suis dépositaire de leur sens du
devoir de leur attachement à la
République et du respect des différences
qui se sont exprimées ces dernières
semaines
[Applaudissements]
je pense aussi à tous nos compatriotes
qui se sont abstenus
leur silence a signifié un refus de
choisir
auquel nous nous devrons aussi de
répondre
je pense enfin à ceux qui ont voté pour
Madame Le Pen dont je sais la déception
ce soir non le sifflet personne
depuis le début je vous ai demandé de ne
jamais siffler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que
dès à présent
je ne suis plus le candidat d'un camp
mais le président de toutes et tous
et je sais que pour nombre de nos
compatriotes
qui ont choisi aujourd'hui l'extrême
droite
la colère et les désaccords qui les ont
conduits à voter pour ce projet
doivent aussi trouver une réponse ce
sera ma responsabilité et celle de ceux
qui m'entourent
car le vote de ce jour
nous impose de considérer toutes les
difficultés dévies vécues et de répondre
avec efficacité au colère qui se sont
exprimés
mes chers compatriotes mes chers amis
aujourd'hui
vous avez fait le choix d'un projet
humaniste ambitieux pour l'indépendance
de notre pays pour notre Europe un
projet républicain dans ses valeurs
un projet social et écologique un projet
fondé sur le travail et la création
un projet de libération de nos forces
académiques culturelles
entrepreneuriales
ce projet
[Applaudissements]
ce projet je veux le porter avec force
pour les années qui viennent
en étant dépositaire aussi
des divisions qui se sont exprimées et
des différences et en veillant chaque
jour au respect de chacun et en
continuant devrait à une société plus
juste et à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
[Applaudissements]
alors pour cela
il nous faudra être exigeant et
ambitieux
nous avons tant à faire
et la guerre en Ukraine est là pour nous
rappeler que nous traversons des temps
tragiques
ou la France se doit de porter sa voix
de montrer la clarté de ses choix
et de bâtir sa force dans tous les
domaines et nous le ferons
et il nous faudra aussi mes amis être
bienveillant
et respectueux car notre pays est pétri
de tant de doute le temps de division
alors il nous faudra être fort
mais nul ne sera laissé au bord du
chemin
alors il nous reviendra ensemble devrait
cette unité par laquelle seul nous
pourrons vivre plus heureux en France
et relever les défis qui nous attendent
les années à venir à coup sûr
ne seront pas tranquilles
mais elles seront historiques et
ensemble nous aurons à les écrire pour
nos générations
alors mes chers compatriotes
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes c'est avec
ambition et bienveillance pour notre
pays pour nous tous
que je veux pouvoir à vos côtés
aborder les cinq années qui viennent
cette terre nouvelle ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
mais l'invention collective d'une
méthode refondée pour cinq années de
mieux au service de notre pays de notre
jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
chacun d'entre nous il y aura une
responsabilité
chacun d'entre nous aura assis engagé
car chacun d'entre nous compte plus que
lui-même
c'est ce qui fait
du peuple français
cette force singulière
que j'aime si profondément si
intensément et que je suis si fier de
servir à nouveau
[Applaudissements]
vive la république
et vive la France
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors aux enfants
[Applaudissements]
les jours de gloire
est arrivé
contre
nous
[Musique]
on donne des
mots campagnes
muscurance
soldats
[Musique]
égorger vos fils vos combats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà donc vous avez pu suivre en
direct le discours de victoire
d'Emmanuel Macron un discours plutôt
court
ou notamment le président de la
République a promis une méthode refondée
pour la gestion du pays les colères et
les désaccords qui ont conduit à voter
pour l'extrême droite doivent trouver
une réponse à notamment dit un Emmanuel
Macron qui semblait ému une réaction un
commentaire Céline d'abord avec vous oui
alors c'est un discours où il a voulu se
montrer très rassembleur aussi en
expliquant que ce vote l'obliger pour
les années à venir qu'il fallait
respecter les différences qui se sont
exprimées
ces dernières semaines il a parlé à son
électorat mais surtout finalement aux
autres c'est à dire ceux qui se sont
absolus ceux qui ont voté pour Marine Le
Pen
en demandant à la foule d'arrêter de
siffler quand son nom a été prononcé et
c'est vrai que là-dessus on retrouve un
peu le ton de sa campagne de second tour
j'allais dire ça sa seule vraie campagne
puisqu'il a pas vraiment fait campagne
avant le premier tour
ou on a vu Emmanuel Macron faire
lui qu'on avait connu libéral
incarnant la startup nation est plutôt
quelqu'un alors retournant plutôt vers
la gauche parlant de d'écologie et là il
a parlé d'une grande nation alors d'une
grande nation écologique donc
ce qu'on a senti dans ce discours qui
est qui était dit sans enfin j'ai
l'impression de s'en a un enthousiasme
sans grand enthousiasme assez
sérieusement peut-être très gravement
c'est que il avait je trouvais des
accents presque de Jacques Chirac qui en
2002 faisait un discours qui ne parlait
plus à son camp mais à tous les Français
c'est plutôt la tonalité de ce discours
ce soir
que le premier tour avait et puis
pendant toute la campagne aussi il y a
eu beaucoup de colère de mécontentements
qui s'étaient exprimés je pense aussi
qu'il y a beaucoup plus d'humilité dans
ce discours pour ça que ce qu'il a pu
notamment
faire état pendant toute la campagne
même pendant son quinquennat beaucoup
d'humilité beaucoup d'union à plusieurs
reprises aussi il a remercié il a dit
merci et puis il s'est présenté avec sa
femme sur sur le
l'estrade alors ça effectivement
qu'est-ce que ça signifie en tout cas
aux yeux de l'opinion c'est certainement
intéressant à décrypter je pense qu'il
veut incarner aussi une certaine union
en fait on lui a beaucoup reproché de
diriger seul être seul sans équipe etc
alors il est pas jusqu'à François
Hollande ou aller sur le pipi avec enfin
sur le l'estrade avec toute une équipe
son stage de campagne etc il reste quand
même le mettre à bord mais il inclut
petit à petit finalement des proches et
pour montrer aussi qu'il n'est pas tout
seul dans sa présidence Guillaume un
commentaire sur ce qu'on a vu également
en plus de ce discours moi j'avoue que
je n'ai pas exactement la même le même
sentiment que vous
je trouve qu'on retrouve le même en même
temps que à quelque peu schizophrénique
d'habitude il arrive avec l'hymne à la
joie donc l'hymne européen et il termine
avec la Marseillaise
le chant de l'armée du Rhin qui est
quand même le champ militaire de la
République révolutionnaire qui combat
les les autres pays européens parce que
justement la République française a
déclaré la guerre en 1792 à l'Europe bon
il demande de ne pas siffler Marine Le
Pen mais il ne cesse de la qualifier
délibérément d'extrême droite ce qui a
pour but évidemment de la disqualifier
d'utiliser une expression infamante et
puis de l'autre côté il cherche il a
repris d'ailleurs le même les mêmes
aspects que le discours de de Marseille
le seul meeting qui les fait dans de
tour le fait que il se voulait le
parangon le champion
de l'Europe de la République de
l'écologie de la jeunesse de
l'initiative bon disons que je suis pas
sûr que dans cette manière de présenter
les choses il y ait forcément une totale
humilité de sa part si on a l'occasion
dans la soirée de revenir sur le la
question des législatives je crois que
il y a évidemment un comment dire un
boulevard devant lui pour cela parce
qu'il y aura une démobilisation des
camps qui ont perdu la présidentielle et
pour autant encore faudrait-il que et
bien il y ait il n'y est pas je dirais
de mouvement sociaux dans les 50 jours
qui nous séparent maintenant de de du
premier tour des législatives or là il
me semble tout de même que en prétendant
avoir le monopole d'un certain nombre de
certaines notions
bah ils ne crée pas les conditions je
dirais de la de la paix civile de la
paix de la Concorde oui je sens en
suivre à ça d'ailleurs on sera en direct
le 1er mai pour suivre justement les
manifestations et les mobilisations
sociales donc c'est dimanche prochain
avant de donner la parole à Maxime Laury
qui va nous faire encore un point info
lors et
vous allez nous quitter donc un mode
conclusion peut-être sur cette soirée
sur ce qu'on a également vécu ensemble
c'est pas forcément une conclusion mais
en tout cas une information ce qui va
être intéressant dans les prochains
jours c'est de décrypter quel est
l'électorat des deux derniers finalistes
on a déjà des premiers chiffres et on
voit que 64% des chômeurs ont voté pour
Marine Le Pen seulement 36% pour
Emmanuel Macron les personnes qui sont
inférieurs à bac + 5
au bac ont voté 50% pour Macron 50% pour
le peine mais ceux qui sont pas plus 3
74% pour Macron 26% pour Le Pen donc on
voit quand même des différences très
marquées dans l'électorat des deux des
deux derniers candidats et je pense
effectivement qu'il va falloir trouver
un moyen de réconcilier quelque part les
cadres les employés les ouvriers qui ont
voulu exprimer là une vision
complètement différente de ce qu'ils
attendaient à l'égard de la France et de
son président
je pense que ce soit il y avait peu
d'envolés de notre Président dans son
discours peu de joie de la victoire en
tout cas c'est comme ça que les uns les
autres l'ont repris mais sans doute
est-ce que c'est effectivement un
précédent qui est élu donc c'est ce qui
l'attend et c'est ce qui est devant lui
il sait que la France est fracturée que
il va falloir aider les Français à se
réconcilier entre eux aussi parce que il
y a des oppositions entre les
générations entre les les la ville et
les gens qui vivent à la campagne la
France est assez fracturée fracturé donc
peut-être était-il conscient qu'il a un
enjeu devant lui assez important
d'autant que les colères sont là et on
le voit dès ce soir parce qu'il y a des
des petits bouts et même très beaucoup
dire mais voilà rassemblement de tension
ça va pas être si simple de faire en
sorte que des gens qui ne se comprennent
pas forcément toujours arrivent de nous
voir se comprendre donc c'est peut-être
ça qui explique qu'il n'y avait pas
d'envolé ce soir la cantatrice qui
toujours été la Marseillaise s'appelle
Farah el diblani et elle est d'origine
et égyptienne et voilà donc les
internautes vous remercient parce que si
vous saviez la litanie
on a donné on s'est permis de donner
cette affirmation cette information et
on va être venu en tout cas merci à vous
Maxime Laurie vous avez la parole pour
nous rappeler les dernières informations
et les principaux points du discours
d'Emmanuel Macron merci Vincent et un et
deux et 50 plus continuent de scander
les partisans d'Emmanuel Macron ce soir
lors de son discours au chant de mars
prononcé juste à l'instant il a dit
t'avoir conscience que ce vote l'oblige
pour les années à venir et promis de
répondre avec efficacité aux colères qui
se sont exprimés durant ces cinq
premières années de mandat le président
qui est d'ailleurs arrivé au pied de la
Tour Eiffel au son de l'hymne européen
plus qu'un clin d'oeil puisque c'est
toute une partie du vieux continent qui
s'est félicité de la victoire du le
président sortant ce soir vos électeurs
ont envoyé un engagement fort à l'Europe
aujourd'hui a déclaré le chancelier
allemand Olaf Scholtz à destination
d'Emmanuel Macron je suis heureux que
nous continuions notre bonne coopération
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
italiens Luigi Mayo a également félicité
le président élu ajoutant que ce n'est
qu'avec une forte dynamique
pro-européenne que nous pourrons
continuer à mener tous ensemble des
combats importants en faveur des
citoyens et la réaction d'Emmanuel
Macron a aussi largement été soutenu par
la classe politique française Anne
Hidalgo et à Valérie Pécresse sont
adressés des félicitations républicaines
à Monsieur Macron ce soir en soulignant
tout de même que notre pays est fracturé
et qu'il ne pourra se réunir que dans la
justice sociale face à la réélection du
président le candidat communiste Fabien
Roussel a lui appeler ce soir un accord
global de la gauche pour les
législatives afin d'éviter toute
division et aller ensemble à la conquête
d'une majorité de députés des réactions
plus cordiales que celles d'Éric Zemmour
qui s'est aussi supprimer dans la soirée
c'est la huitième fois que la défaite
frappe le nom de Le Pen je voyais cette
défaite venir depuis des années à deal
ex-candidat en réaction aux résultats de
cette élection il a également appelé à
l'Union nationale pour les législatives
des 12 et 19 juin prochain un appel
auquel a répondu le président du
Rassemblement national Jordan Bardella
en promettant que le parti ne
s'enfermerait pas dans une alliance avec
reconquête pour Marine Le Pen le
résultat de ce soir représente tout de
même une victoire à te dit juste après
l'annonce des résultats depuis ce QG au
pavillon d'armeonville dans un discours
d'acceptation la candidate battue a
promis de continuer le combat pour
préparer notamment la grande bataille
électorale des législatives enfin un
point sur les scores de ce soir une
nouvelle fois selon les dernières
estimations le président réélu a obtenu
58% des voix contre 42% pour Marine Le
Pen
merci Maxime Lorie on vous retrouve dans
une demi-heure et on va tout de suite
rejoindre l'autre studio du Figaro le
studio pile et Will ou Thibault Gauthier
a démarré un live serviciel qui vous
répond en temps réel pour vous donner
les résultats dans votre commune il est
accompagné d'Alban balarte on vous
écoute
de moi
cette colle écoutez c'est Philippe alors
ce qu'on peut peut-être faire Thibault
si vous êtes d'accord c'est demander à
Philippe de nous donner le code postal
sur facebook voilà exactement Philippe
donnez-nous un peu plus de précisions
sur l'endroit que vous recherchez puis
du coup comme ça on pourra vous donner
les résultats
mais alors j'ai envie de faire plaisir à
quelqu'un Saint-Sauveur dans les
Hautes-Alpes par exemple et à
Saint-Sauveur dans les Hautes-Alpes
regardez Emmanuel Macron est arrivé en
tête avec 59,38% des voix ça ne
m'intéresse probablement personne sur ce
chat mais sachez-le on peut trouver des
résultats dans Saint-Sauveur à
Saint-Sauveur dans les Hautes-Alpes
sur une autre ville Thibault si vous le
voulez
dans le 49 alors dans le 49 vous m'avez
dit mêlé me l y l e un seul e de en tout
cas c'est ce que l'internaute redis-moi
redis-moi
Mey et sachez mais je ne trouve pas vous
n'avez rien pas cette commune alors
sachez quand même que je salue tous les
internautes qui nous rejoignent qui
suivent le grand live la grande soirée
de la présidentielle avec avec Vincent
roux et Bruno Audrey si vous nous
rejoignez ici on vous donne les
résultats dans votre commune vous nous
rejoignez sur notre sur notre live à
nous sur Figaro.fr sur YouTube sur
Facebook on tape le nom de votre commune
et on trouve les résultats si elle bande
faire un effort parce que depuis tout à
l'heure je peux vous dire que des
communes on n'a pas les résultats Jacou
Thibault
[Musique]
il me semble et bien c'est une des c'est
dans le département de l'Hérault c'est
la région regardez à Jacou et bien c'est
tout simple c'était manuel Macron qui
arrive en tête 2200 voix ça fait
64,25% des suffrages Marine Le Pen est à
35,75 c'est assez logique 1 et puis
l'abstention on a bien voté à Jacques où
regarder seulement 21% d'abstention les
en blanc et nul assez élevé évidemment
presque 8% de blanc presque 2% allez de
de votre nul et puis on peut comparer
allons comparer c'est ce qu'on fait ici
sur ce live on peut voir par rapport à
2017 Emmanuel Macron a donc réalisé
64,25 % en 2022 en 2017 il était à 69 il
a légèrement baissé et ça ça se
caractérise également au niveau national
voilà pour les résultats Jacou et
c'était Yannick qui nous posait la
question enfin vous faites un effort
vous mettez au niveau 1 dès qu'il y a le
grand live avec nous pour nous regarder
là je vois que vous faites un effort
alors essayez de mettre au niveau tout
le temps nous sommes une équipe de très
haut niveau chambre un peu mais comme
c'est que vous êtes exécutif de Figaro
live d'ailleurs alors j'ai une autre
question une autre commune pour vous
c'est Estelle sur facebook Estelle qui
nous demande les résultats pour
Landerneau Landerneau dans la dans le
Finistère en Bretagne Landerneau
Landerneau exactement
dans le Finistère commune de 15914
habitants suspense à Landerneau qui est
arrivé en tête c'est Emmanuel Macron 71%
des suffrages voilà et donc vous avez
les résultats dans votre commune et vous
avez vu c'est une ambiance extrêmement
sympathique avec
Thibault et Gauthier et Alban Barthélemy
Thibault Gauthier d'ailleurs qui
reprendra le live dès demain matin à
partir de 7h30 oui commentera avec
Stéphane Rosas c'est résultat nous avons
également les images en ce moment de
Emmanuel Macron au Champ de Mars qui est
en bain de foule avec derrière lui car
le livre bonsoir je dis
le maire de le maire de Poissy ça aussi
c'est le symbole du Ralliement d'une
partie de la droite à Emmanuel Macron
car le livre de cachait pas sa très
forte sympathie pour Emmanuel Macron
avec lequel il avait une ligne directe
il se flattait d'ailleurs d'être souvent
son relais sur le terrain de lui d'être
un des rares à lui raconter ce que les
mers ressentaient
merci
je salue également Victor
général de bac bonne Consulting qui nous
a rejoint on va aller justement sur le
Champ de Mars retrouvé Matisse fleuret
qui a interrogé des militants
oui Vincent et bien je suis oui en
direct sur le Champ de Mars avec Joey
qui est militant lrem alors Macron vient
de prendre la parole qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé de son discours j'ai trouvé
ça très intéressant mais j'ai trouvé ça
un peu plus faible effectivement que en
2017 vraiment après je vous avoue que du
coup j'ai été militant surtout en 2017
là cette année j'ai pas tellement eu le
temps mais j'ai trouvé moins la ferveur
que qu'en 2010 7 mais ce qui est normal
aussi je pense et du coup est-ce que
vous espérez quand même quelque chose
pour la suite et pour le prochain
quinquennat oui bien sûr il a eu un
quinquennat affreux il faut le dire
clairement le covid il y a l'Ukraine il
y a eu les gilets jaunes quand on me dit
bah oui mais Macron n'a rien fait oui
mais en même temps 5 ans comme ça on le
souhaite à personne franchement même à
son pire ennemi donc oui je pense qu'il
peut faire quelque chose après à lui de
nous le prouver maintenant et de nous le
montrer pourquoi il y a pourquoi il y
avait moins de ferveur qu'en 2017 vous
trouvez
je peut-être que les gens s'en doutaient
un peu plus parce qu'avec les
estimations et le fait qu'il est déjà
été Président je sais pas j'ai trouvé
vraiment qu'il y avait moins de moi
cette ferveur et aussi parce que là
campagne il faut le dire elle a été
lancée peut-être un peu un peu trop tard
avec Macron et donc je pense que ça
faiblit à cause de ça merci beaucoup de
Joey pour pour cette prise de parole
voilà Vincent brune je vous rends la
parole justement merci beaucoup Mathis
vous la reprenez quand vous voulez on
vous donnera la parole ainsi que au
militants qui sont regroupés autour de
vous et surtout autour du président
réélu bonsoir Victor Boury bonsoir c'est
ce qui est en train de monter sur les
réseaux sociaux vous qui les avez
scrutés pendant que Véronique a commenté
ici alors depuis les l'annonce des
résultats de l'élection on a observé
quatre types de réactions
essentiellement les premiers c'est les
soutiens du président réélu qui est qui
exprime leur satisfaction on a le
hashtag 50 plus qui a beaucoup circulé
dès le début de l'annonce beaucoup de
messages aussi des électeurs qui ont
voté par raison avec le hashtag
démocratie #soulagement qui a été
notamment beaucoup beaucoup relayé et
ensuite un grand un fort volume et le
volume qui est qui prédominant des
électeurs déçus ou abstentionnistes avec
le fameux Macron démission les hashtags
42% aussi qui sont également aussi
utilisés par les macronistes les plus
violents on va dire pour pointer du
doigt ce type d'électeur comment une
aussi importante partie des Français
pouvaient voter pour un pour un parti il
y a aussi le acheter gradueland qui a
circulé toute la journée qui était le
hashtag qui a rassemblé l'ensemble des
communautés entier anti-machronistes et
enfin les les abstentionnistes
mélenchonistes avec le hashtag Mélenchon
en métinion qui a pris en toute en tout
début de soirée qui nous rappelle une
fois de plus que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
sur les réseaux sociaux comme dans les
médias on l'a vu ce soir il s'est
exprimé et résolument le troisième homme
de cette élection
je lui dis
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
résultat qui se situe dans la moyenne
haute de l'écart que prévoyait les
sondages depuis sa qualification au
premier tour
Marine Le Pen n'avait cessé de voir
l'écart se creuser avec Emmanuel Macron
donc là les sondages ont parfaitement
décrit la dynamique qui était en train
de d'opérer et qui s'est vérifié
aucune raison de se réjouir de l'état de
la France qui se reflète à travers ce
scrutin et à travers ce résultat une
France extrêmement divisée malgré sa
défaite Marine Le Pen fait un score que
n'avait jamais fait la droite radicale
dans ce pays
une abstention
gigantesissime alors je crois que les
dernières vérifications sont en cours
mais après ce serait la plus forte de la
Cinquième République pour l'élection
présidentielle donc plus encore que
celle de 1969 alors je vous dis les
vérifications sont encore en cours il
faut toujours voir ce qu'on parait ce
qui est comparable voire avec le nombre
d'inscrits etc etc mais en tout cas ça
se situe dans ces eaux là sachant que à
l'élection de 69
contre Pompidou c'était pas
deux projets radicalement opposés
pour la France qui se présente
bonnet blanc célèbre formule voilà donc
une France extrêmement divisée
d'ailleurs
cette gravité de la situation je trouve
ces refléter dans les termes d'Emmanuel
Macron qui nous a pas fait de discours
triomphalisme et au contraire a donné
beaucoup de place à tous les gens qui
n'avaient pas voté pour lui et même qui
ayant voté pour lui ne l'avait pas fait
par adhésion à son projet mais pour
faire barrage selon l'expression
désormais consacrée votre castor un
commentaire je vous vois on commence à
voir aussi les dans différents sondages
qui ont été fait le jour du vote quelles
sont les motivations des électorats en
comparaison on voit notamment que dans
l'électorats de Marine Le Pen on a
beaucoup parlé du pouvoir d'achat et
c'est vraiment ceux qui ressort vraiment
de chez ceux qui ont voté Marine Le Pen
et d'ailleurs pendant le débat elle n'a
pas été
si efficace que ça j'ai trouvé enfin
personnellement sur ce sur ce thème là
parce que assez vite elle s'est fait
piéger par Emmanuel Macron elle est
partie sur des considérations un peu
plus économiques elle aurait sans doute
pu enfoncer le clou un peu plus encore
sur une thématique sur laquelle elle
était vraiment privilégiée et jugée plus
crédible par une majorité de Français
donc c'est vraiment ce thème là qui est
ressorti mais l'immigration
très fortement également c'est à dire
que les gens qui ont voté Marine Le Pen
le font en premier et assez largement
pour le pouvoir d'achat ils sont les
deux tiers à le dire et ils sont 55% à
dire c'est pour l'immigration à cause de
l'immigration je sais pas comment il
faut prononcer les choses qu'on voit que
du fait de l'admiration qu'on vote
Marine Le Pen alors que on voit que du
côté d'Emmanuel Macron c'est beaucoup
plus dispersé les raisons de voter
Emmanuel Macron alors il y a du vote
rejet il y a le fait que des gens
puissent avoir peur quand candidats
qu'une candidate d'extrême droite prenne
le pouvoir mais il y a pas vraiment de
thème qui ressort à part aussi le
pouvoir d'achat mais moins fortement que
que Marine Le Pen on voyait chez les
lectorat proche d'Emmanuel Macron cette
idée aussi que c'était un candidat plus
solide qui était quand même plus à même
de faire en sorte que la France se
relève des différentes crises vécues à
la fois le covid à la fois l'Ukraine et
donc c'est ça qui ressort le plus si je
puis dire et après notamment beaucoup
plus cité évidemment que chez les
sympathisants de Marine Le Pen l'Europe
c'est un thème qui compte pour
l'électorat qui s'est déplacé pour voter
manuel Macron un électorat qui ressemble
quand même beaucoup à cet électorat de
base ce socle qu'il a eu au premier tour
qui n'a pas été qui a été un peu
amplifiée mais qui ressemble beaucoup
sociologiquement à son électorat de
premier tour ce soir d'ailleurs c'était
ambivalent dans ce qu'on a soit quoi en
assisté autant en 2000 en 2017 vraiment
le thème européen était au centre du de
la victoire là il y avait l'hymne à la
joie d'un côté et de l'autre quand même
peu de drapeau enfin le l'arrière fond
de d'Emmanuel Macron c'était c'était un
drapeau tricolore il y avait pas de il y
a pas de drapeau européen Guillaume
Bernard c'était quand même l'élection
pour la présidence de la République
française
un drapeau européen en lieu et place du
drapeau bleu blanc rouge sous l'Arc de
Triomphe absolument alors cela dit il
est certain que il avait un public qui
était acquis qui était là et que les
images qui étaient tournées elles
n'étaient pas faites que pour ces
électeurs mais pour toutes les chaînes
de télévision et y compris des étrangers
donc il fallait utiliser les symboles
qui permettaient d'identifier rapidement
à quoi correspondait à quoi
correspondait les images
moi je crois que ce qui va vraiment être
nécessaire d'étudier très attentivement
c'est la répartition sociologique et
géographique des deux électorats parce
que ça sera encore un dangereuse je suis
obsédé par les législatives et que je
veux à tout prix en venir à chaque fois
mais enfin il est bien évident que si
vous avez des concentrations
géographiques et sociologiques à
certains endroits qui permettent à des
parties d'opposition d'avoir des élus ça
jouera un rôle et ça permettra je dirais
d'avoir une assemblée qui ne soit pas
quasiment monolithique parce que vers
quoi on
s'oriente a priori une chambre du même
style que celle de 1993 c'est-à-dire 450
députés d'un même camp politique sauf
que ça sera plus la plateforme rprdv ça
sera ça sera le la grande coalition
macronienne en revanche il est possible
alors pourquoi pourquoi on s'oriente
vers ça parce qu'en fait
ce qu'on appelle sous la Cinquième
République le phénomène majoritaire un
président nouvellement élu obtient une
majorité de la même couleur politique
que la sienne à l'Assemblée
démobilisations de l'électorat qui a
perdu sauf que tant que vous étiez dans
un duel droit de gauche pour dire les
choses rapidement vous aviez un camp qui
avait perdu là je vous signale que vous
avez plus d'un camp qui a perdu
l'élection présidentielle ce soir vous
avez le camp de Marine Le Pen ou la
droite nationale elle est avec ses mots
vous avez le camp de Mélenchon et vous
avez le camp des abstentionnistes qui
grossit donc si vous avez une
démobilisation de tous les camps qui
comment dire qui qui ont perdu ce soir
et bien vous avez une une
sur-représentation encore plus grande de
ceux qui continuent à aller voter c'est
à dire ceux qui ont voté pour Emmanuel
Macron ce soir donc on s'oriente a
priori c'est ceux qui fantasme sur
l'idée on va imposer une cohabitation à
Macron je voudrais pas les décevoir j'ai
pas de boule de cristal naturellement il
peut toujours arriver des choses
étonnantes a priori ça n'arrivera pas en
revanche qui sera intéressant de voir et
c'est je reviens au début de mon propos
c'est de voir la répartition
géographique des votes pour notamment
Marine Le Pen ou Jean-Luc Mélenchon les
banlieues islamisés qui ont voté pour
Mélenchon les la France périphérique
populaire en chômage qui a voté pour
Marine Le Pen ça c'est un indicateur
quand même ce soir c'est quand même que
les outre-mer ont voté massivement
hormis la Nouvelle-Calédonie la
Polynésie pour Marine
un caractère spécifique
au vote des Outre-mer c'est la covid et
la gestion de la crise sanitaire qui a
dans la plupart des cas inversés le
rapport de force qui s'était exprimé en
2017 Marine Le Pen a fait des scores
qu'elle avait jamais fait outre-mer à
cause de ça à cause d'une gestion qui a
été extrêmement mal ressentie de la
crise sanitaire en métropole la
suspension des soignants qui refusaient
de se faire
vacciné a été mal vécu mais alors là-bas
ça a été une révolution
d'autant plus violente qui avait une
pénurie
de médecins d'infirmière de d'équipement
hospitaliers tout tous les les mots de
l'outre-mer ont été démultipliés et avec
une gestion quand même un peu
erratique de Paris en souvient des
hésitations faut-il aller sur place pas
aller sur place et on se souvient
surtout que les premiers renforts qui
ont été envoyés ont été des renforts
policiers avant les renforts sanitaires
d'envergure
il y a d'autres cas le cas de Mayotte
par rapport aussi est extrêmement
intéressant alors c'est un tout petit
territoire c'est peuplé et c'est une
population qui est à très forte majorité
je dirais de pratiques religieuses
musulmane mais qui en même temps subit
l'immigration clandestine Mayotte a voté
la majorité mariement pour pour Marine
Le Pen donc c'est vrai que il y a quand
même un certain nombre de symboles
Marine Le Pen supposément
islamophobe et supposément raciste
évidemment qui voit Mayotte et
l'outre-mer voté majoritairement pour
elle disons que ça crée je dirais des
des perspectives intéressantes mais il
manquait voilà évidemment Victor Boris
sur les résultats dans les DOM-TOM il y
a une analyse qu'on peut faire justement
de de la contestation de la colère dans
dans ces territoires-là sur les réseaux
sociaux on avait pu l'identifier en fait
il y a plusieurs même plusieurs années
pendant fin de pendant l'intégralité du
quinquennat sur les sujets qui
arrivaient un peu tard dans la politique
du le président récemment élu à savoir
le sujet du pouvoir d'achat qui était
préempté au départ pas à Marine Le Pen
et sur le sujet du prix des produits de
du coût de la vie c'est des dynamiques
qu'on avait pu observer alors que si on
compare aux résultats de l'élection de
2017 ou au secteur en moyenne à 75 %
pour améliorer on se revirement et cette
colère montante c'est vraiment des
dynamiques qu'on a pu voir en observant
les réseaux on disait que par exemple on
l'a vu je dis ça en régissant aux
chiffres des Outre-mer mais par exemple
que finalement le mouvement
anti-pasanitaire anti-pas vaccinal était
finalement minoritaire ou marginal dans
l'opinion finalement quand même ça a des
ça a des effets électoraux quand même ce
soir oui enfin c'est de toute façon
c'est parce qu'on regarde toujours les
les la majorité et il est très clair que
le mouvement antivax
n'a pas été plutôt quand même
complètement rejeté par une majorité de
Français qui se sont montrées tout à
fait
d'ailleurs pas tout pas dès le départ
mais en tout cas quand ils sont étaient
convaincus par le vaccin ce sont mis
très très vite à l'adopter et à rejeter
le mouvement anti-axe reste que ça fait
partie de ses colères sur lesquels
Marine Le Pen a pu compter c'est à dire
que le vote Marine Le Pen reste très
largement un vote de colère à les
colères peuvent être variés ça peut être
la colère contre un pouvoir d'achat
dégradé ça peut être la colère contre
une immigration qui serait jugée
débridée c'est ça a été beaucoup la
colère contre le vaccin obligatoire mais
aussi contre les règles sanitaires qui
pour une part de la population ont été
mal acceptées et Marine Le Pen a pu
compter aussi sur ces petits bastions
pour pouvoir faire un score qui même
s'il n'est pas la hauteur de ces
espérances ce soir est un score très
important pour une élue issue du
rassemblement national mais il faut pas
confondre qui va accenti passe sanitaire
et à fortiori anti pass vaccinale
c'était des minorités de la population
c'était parmioritaire de la population
anti-vax purée dur
ultra minoritaire évidemment
antipase ça évolué au fur et à mesure
qu'on découvrait qu'en fait le vaccin ne
protégeait pas de la contamination donc
ça a quand même profondément
la population
de révolte en France alors que chez tous
nos voisins je suis la plupart de nos
voisins mais je pense même à l'Allemagne
il y a eu des manifs et des manifs très
violents dès les premières mesures de
contrats adopter comme le couvre-feu
alors c'est la vie ça veut dire que il y
a toujours dans le pays
un certain nombre de ferments diraient
de disputes de d'affrontement politique
et sociaux qui ne sont toujours pas
réglés pense que l'augmentation du coût
de la vie c'est tout de même une des
raisons qu'il y a mené aux gilet jaune
la question du Pass sanitaire elle est
toujours pas véritablement réglé puisque
on le sait bien il y a des obligations
notamment de voyages dans le cadre de
l'Union européenne qui commence à
s'appliquer à partir de mi-juin et qui
vont de nouveau nécessiter le fait
d'avoir un pass pour pouvoir voyager sur
les lignes aériennes au sein de l'Union
européenne donc ça veut dire que il y a
tous les ingrédients pour que malgré la
réélection d'Emmanuel Macron et bien il
y est de nouveau décontestations et
c'est sans doute cela dans les semaines
à venir qu'il va falloir regarder parce
que et pardonnez-moi d'y revenir mais il
y a eu à la fois une augmentation de
l'abstention ce soir mais une diminution
du score d'Emmanuel Macron en
pourcentage et il n'augmentation du
nombre de voix de Marine Le Pen de 2,5
millions c'est-à-dire alors qu'il y a
une augmentation de l'abstention elle a
augmenté son de 2017 de 2,5 millions bon
moi je veux bien qu'effectivement
Emmanuel Macron soit élu enfin c'est bon
je veux bien
je me suis mal exprimé vous avez très
bien compris ce que je veux dire il est
réélu ça n'empêche que c'est une défaite
de Marine Le Pen enfin une défaite avec
2 millions et demi de voix en plus quoi
donc c'est pas euh
quel que soit par ailleurs les
préférences de chacun exactement
si vous nous rejoignez il est presque
22h30 on va bientôt accueillir Maxime
Laurie pour un prochain point info en
tout cas je continue de vous suivre et
de vous lire dans Le Chat Claudius 15
qui me dit ou brune on est là mais je
vous regarde je vous lis alors là en ce
moment ça débat beaucoup autour de
Manuel Valls qui apparemment a été
interviewé chez nos confrères de TF1
voilà savoir s'il était un bon ministre
ou pas voilà je vous pose la question en
tout cas si vous avez d'autres remarques
d'autres questions à nous faire passer
n'oubliez pas que je vous regarde et je
lis vos commentaires et je il n'y a pas
de les relayer en direct Maxime Laurie
est arrivé pour le point info on vous
écoute tout de suite merci brune après
les résultats et les discours se sont
maintenant quelques rassemblements qui
rythmes une partie de la soirée des
personnes sont actuellement groupées
place de la République à Paris par
exemple bien encadré par les forces de
l'ordre la situation il est calme et la
circulation maintenue au moment où je
vous parle nous aurons du Le Pen avec
Macron a mis en garde la candidate
Natalie Arthaud se soit qui a été l'une
des dernières à réagir à la réaction à
la réélection pardon du Président
sortant dans un communiqué dans un autre
registre les partisans d'Emmanuel Macron
continuent de scander et 1 et 2 et 50
plus ce soir au Champ de Mars lors de
son discours prononcer peu avant 22h le
président réélu a dit d'avoir conscience
que ce vote l'oblige pour les années à
venir et promis de répondre avec
efficacité aux colères qui se sont
exprimés durant ces cinq premières
années demanda interrogés par une
journaliste de TF1 Brigitte Macron a
également réagi à la réélection de son
mari c'est un immense et je veux
remercier tous les Français qui lui ont
fait confiance a-t-elle dit en direct le
couple présidentiel qui est d'ailleurs
arrivé au pied de la Tour Eiffel au son
de l'hymne européen plus qu'un clin
d'oeil puisque c'est toute une partie du
jeu continent qui s'est félicité de la
victoire du président sortant côté
Marine Le Pen dans un discours
d'acceptation à son QG au Pavillon
d'Armenonville juste après l'annonce des
résultats ce soir la candidate battue a
promis de continuer le combat pour